this is Jocko podcast number 353 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
my Brave fellows
you have done all I asked you to do and
more than can be reasonably expected
but your country is at stake
your wives your houses and all that you
hold dear
you have worn worn yourselves out with
fatigues and hardships
but we know not how to spare you
if you will consent to stay one month
longer you will render that service to
the cause of Liberty and to your country
which you probably can never do under
any other circumstances
and that right there was a
quote from
George Washington
encouraging his men to re-enlist in the
Army and he made that speech on Tuesday
December 31st 1776 this was less than a
week after
the successful attack at Trenton
and great victory for Washington's Army
the one that everybody knows about
Crossing the Delaware River
and able to achieve this Victory but the
men had suffered greatly
prior to that they'd lost a battle of
White Plains in October uh the battle at
forts at Washington in November their
uniforms when you when you read about
what condition they were in they were
just in tatters and Rags at this point
some of them didn't have shoes
by the way December in the Northeast
so this is the last day of the year
December 31st and
interestingly most of the soldiers
enlistments they'd enlisted for a year
or two years and so a lot of the
soldiers their enlistments were up
at the end of the year
and this was a potential disaster for
the Army
but through this personal appeal
Washington convinced about half of the
men to stay and carry on and they were
able to defeat the British
at Princeton and kind of revived the
morale of the Continental Army
but that just put that question in my
into my mind is when is enough enough
and we call on our service men and women
to do so much
and it's amazing when they decide
to continue to serve
and it's an honor here to have one of
those men with us tonight retired seal
26 years of service husband father
teammate friend of mine
who deployed to Iraq deployed to
Afghanistan
Africa Asia Europe South America Central
America and he's looking to continue his
service now his name is Derek Van Orden
we used to call him van o that's right
vano Derek thanks for coming down man
thank you for having me good to see you
it's good to see you too they now call
me dvo
dvo I don't know why I mean I do you
gotta have the three letters uh you know
what that's that's a little too close to
deviant
I don't know if I like that yeah
speaking of that man so I've never been
to your place here it's it's marvelous
and uh went to the head that's the
bathroom for folks who are in the Navy
and uh like 30 guys were I was talking
to Echo about this they're all looking
at me like what are you doing
I look like you know hillbilly came
rolling there but uh this is a wonderful
facility here man yeah that's uh well
it's a mixed martial so I guess your
point is a mixed martial arts gym it's
it's literally the middle of
our professional Pro MMA practice is
going on out in the gym so it's the the
alliance team which trains here out of
Victory okay uh with some incredible
Fighters some Champs in there Dominic
Cruz just saw Dom and so yes they're
athletes in Peak Physique in the in the
prime of their athletic careers well I'm
certainly in my Prime
just like Doc Holliday apparently at
this point uh no awesome to see you man
so let's let's start at the beginning
let's start where you came from let's
figure out how you got here today and
let's let's talk about that story so
when where were you born well to begin
in the beginning as they say
um I was raised in abject rural poverty
by a single mom my dad was not honorable
no other way to describe that he
abandoned us when I was an infant and I
dropped out of high school when I was 16
years old hold on a second you got
really quick through a lot of years so
so I was so you're born I was part of
Minneapolis Minnesota my father
abandoned us we had to move in with my
grandmother in Luverne Minnesota what's
LaVerne Minnesota for some reason I
haven't heard of this Metro well you
should have because Ken Burns uh did one
of his uh documentaries called the war
okay it featured the Palace Theater
which is on Main Street in La Verne and
we lived in the apartment above the
Palace Theater once we got enough
together because we had to live with my
grandmother when we were that poor so
what's what's the population of Laverne
I don't know now but it's a small town
it's small town what was your mom doing
to make ends meet uh she was one of the
first female Sports reporters in the
country
and uh she's always been a stats at him
she died nine years ago eight years ago
now my mom just wonderful Carol Ann
Mulligan she's like
you know this tall five foot nothing and
the hardest woodpecker lips she's a
tough man and uh
then she got a job with a company called
Ina which became Cigna insurance and
that's how we wound up in Wisconsin so
we I grew up in Wisconsin southeastern
Wisconsin because my mother got promoted
wait so when did she leave Sports
reporting
which I would have been that was prior
to the insurance thing I don't need the
years but so she was doing that sort of
right it was kind of uh that sort of
stuff right because it was just weird to
have a woman reporting sports you know
it's just now it's now it's common yeah
it's normative so she didn't so she
couldn't quite pull off a career in
sports reporting no that wouldn't happen
but then she went to the insurance
business she started as a secretary okay
and uh then she got promoted she's very
she was very bright and uh she wound up
retiring running the West Coast
for um Cigna she ran this whole office
and it was interesting she um
she's sitting around hearing these
stories it's fascinating because it
helped me later on in my career
as a seal that she was like wait a
minute if we have this phone and we
anyone has a phone they can call this
number
and if they have the ability to
understand what's going on with this
phone they can get everybody's insurance
information
so she was one of the the first people
to get into cyber security because you
had the modem you know what I mean it
didn't matter there was no encryption
there it was if you could have a modem
yeah that sort of stuff yeah so she
started doing remember that you guys are
you know how old are you 44. all right
you remember you're old
um do you remember dial-up Yeah well
yeah yeah look at that
AOL yeah yeah you do so uh she did that
and and um you know I'm not having a
father figure as a dad my Uncle Bob
which is her oldest brother she's one of
10 Irish Catholics and uh Bob left
uh Worthington which is outside of
Laverne when he was 16 years old enjoy
the Navy in World War II there's this
great picture of him he's sitting like
this with his hands over the rail of an
ammunition Oiler right off of Iwo Jima
no shirt on you know just hanging being
a sailor and it's just so fun you know
but um yeah so gunny went to
um was in the Navy and then uh you know
they demobilized everybody after World
War II so he goes back to to Minnesota
can't find a job and he's like man I
need a job this is Uncle Bob we're
talking this is Robert Francis Mulligan
the oldest
brother of yours of your mom of my mom
got it so he was one of ten
and uh so he winds up going back to
Minnesota this is so fun because we're
in San Diego
and uh he goes to the Marine Corps and
he's like you know can I join the
Marines he goes yeah some staff sergeant
sir he goes okay here's your you know
bus ticket to San Diego
and just you'll go to the bus station
take a cab to MCRD which is right down
the road from here and um you know then
you're there and you know Bob's looking
at his feet called the museum feet you
know you don't want to be in a museum
anymore you got to shuffle your feet and
the staff starting worked at him he goes
you don't have enough money for a cab do
you he's like nope so he gives him money
for a cap
so Bob takes the bus cab and Saturday
Marine Corps you know fast forward 20
years or whatever it is he sees this
warrant officer and in the Marine Corps
they call him Gunners and he's like hey
man I think I know you and he and he
goes were you a recruiter in Minnesota
goes yeah I go I'm the guy that you gave
the money for the cab and the Gunner
looks at me goes do you know how many
people I had to give money for a cab
so we think that things are difficult
now and we're getting trust me man the
economy's going into the tank it's bad
but the the level of uh affluence that
we have in the United States of America
now is unprecedented in the history of
the world and that goes across all
spectrums
uh I mean that was like you didn't have
anything so Bob does uh 20 years he goes
to Korea
grievously injured by a Chinese
Communist soldiers throwing a check on
grenade into his Foxhole
and then he winds up going to Laos in
1962. the retired becomes a police
officer in a small village in Wisconsin
called Shaniqua and retired as the chief
of police the fire chief and the village
administrator and he ends up being your
you say your father figure correct what
do you have for brothers and sisters I
have one brother older younger older
okay yeah now what you're now going to
school you used to living above this
theater in Laverne right till I was in
second grade
okay and we moved mom got promoted and
we moved to Heartland Wisconsin
Heartland Heartland just straight up
Heartland Wisconsin yeah man
um so we grew up there we're still very
poor and the apartments we live in now I
think are section 8 housing
um that we lived in then are now I
believe Section 8 Housing and now this
is where you go to Middle School Is this
where you correct go to high school and
stuff no so I we mom got promoted again
and then we moved to Oregon oh okay
right and that's where I was in high
school for a year and two weeks of my
sophomore year were you playing sports
growing up I wrestled okay for my
freshman year
um but I never was into those types of
things I just I never was
my brother is super big in professional
sports clearly my mother was because she
was a sports reporter but um but just
never never did much for me were you
what were you focused on were you
focused on academics it's no you know
what I wasn't I mean I read I've always
been a huge reader like from when I was
a little kid I was always reading and I
was kind of more um
I don't know how to put that I just I
was I was into exploring the world from
a different perspective because
so we were so poor I mean like dirt poor
and I knew I could never collect
material objects because of that and so
from when I was just a little kid I
started collecting relationships with
people
and I have the same friends that I've
had since I was 14.
because I understand the value of human
beings and I understand the value of the
intrinsic nature of somebody's intellect
Vice you know their physical being and
they're they're clearly intertwined one
is part of another but um so for me
that's always been my thing so I've
always really focused on
humans and the the additive value of
people you know the synergistic effect
of getting together you that's how you
create
and um so I've always done that you know
I've done some art stuff and whatever
but
um what's art stuff or whatever sketch I
write poetry and you know
believe it or not so so when you're in
in school are you like hanging out with
the the no the freaking Poetry Club is
that what we got going on no I was wait
were you wearing all black and like oh
my gosh well I am dying your hair black
hey who's wearing all black hair let's
just you guys is this camera working so
no man I was kind of an outsider because
again you know children can be very
cruel
and when I say we report I mean we were
poor so I was ostracized
because of my poverty
and then when we moved to Oregon it was
a very affluent community and you know I
wasn't just on the other side of the
tracks on the other side of the you know
so that can be very
um you can take that one or two
directions you know you you can
consciously choose your path
and you can choose to to ride that into
the dirt
and get into this uh destructive cycle
and we've seen this happen over and over
again you know intergenerational poverty
and all these things and people feel
like they have no way out I mean I was
the
did you ever see someone walk around
with their head down yeah and they walk
like that all the time somebody I ran
into them where did I see him they're
like oh you're so I had dropped out of
high school I was working
you know I've been supporting myself
since I was 16. and someone's like oh I
remember you from high school you're the
guy that always walked with your head
down
and I was like wait a minute
you're right so I started walking with
my head up
and just that simple wait when was that
um I would have been 17 or 18. so when
you're 17 or 18 some oh someone said oh
you used to walk around with your head
down you're the guy they recognized me
you're the guy that would walk around
your head down because I was so I wasn't
self-absorbed but it was like I felt
like
because we were so pouring being you
know just the the other you know that
you know I shouldn't be interacting with
the world around me so I start I put my
head up and I was like that one physical
gesture of going you know I am here and
I'm part of the equation and then that
slowly opens up your aperture and you
start looking around you're like what's
going on here can I do something here
can I do something there
um you know the the visual feedback that
you get from another person actually
enhances your ability to have a
relationship with them which I think is
very important yeah that that posture
thing is huge I had JP to know on this
podcast and I work with him still but
you know I talked about and this was a
long time ago I've talked about the fact
I was watching him like I'm in a like
sitting in a door well or something on a
street in ramadi and I'm watching JP
like maneuver and he's like walking with
his chest out his head up like I come
here just like I'm here I'm gonna get it
and you know a lot of people your
instinct is to especially in combat is
to get small get small right and he's
like no chest up head out and that
became a thing you know this whole
posture thing I mean Jordan Peterson
talked about uh you know stand up
straight with your shoulders back I was
like oh yeah that's that was JP to now
and it sounds like you made that
transition at 17 years old when someone
said dude you're walking around with
your head down yeah that makes it makes
a difference yeah it does and I I think
that uh I don't think I know that people
now you know they can go oh this is a
Brash you know person and
um
but when I sit down with them talk to
them they understand that that's not
posturing it's posture
so then there's a difference between the
two one isn't is something that's
internalized and the other one is a
projection
so if you have posture that's that's
you've internalized that you're
posturing you're pretending I don't
pretend about really anything
um so you're going to high school you're
ostracized
and at some point you say you decide to
drop out of high amount the institution
no longer had anything to offer me that
is a direct quote for manawas I think
yeah it's a direct quote from what
animal house I believe okay so you
decide what does your mom say about this
I'm not happy yeah I was gonna say
there's no Mom that's like oh cool
you're dropping out of high school no
we're stoked she was not happy at all
what was your plan I didn't have one
had you already been working
uh yeah I started working I think when I
was 14. and so what are you doing I work
at a movie theater cool and then I
worked at a gas station Roger yeah
Chevron gas station gas fixing cars and
and now you must uh so what's your
reasoning behind dropping out of school
how do you come to this conclusion I was
success it was I don't think the
environment was oppressive I just I just
didn't fit okay and I just didn't want
to be part of that so you tell your mom
what what was it in the school year was
in the summer time it was two weeks into
my sophomore year
I'm out yeah I get them out and then I
moved out and um so what'd you get for a
job I was working at the gas station oh
okay so the gas station job you move
into an apartment or something yeah
that was it I mean so
you know do I recommend this life path I
mean I did that I got an undergraduate
degree at 44 I got accepted law school
of 50 you know that sort of stuff would
I recommend this path
um that's a very complicated answer
because in some ways I would say yes in
other ways I would not and I was
thinking about this because I was going
to come talk to you
um if you look at
what's taking place in the world right
now
um I think if more people had more
adversity
growing up
that they would be able to thrive more I
mean I'm going to get elected to
congress next year that's happened
actually this year November I'll take
office next year and I started from the
meanest circumstances you possibly can I
mean abstract real poverty broken home
single mom enlisted guy in the Navy
and you know I'm going to be in the
highest levels of power in the most
powerful country in the world within a
single generation
I tell people this all this time all the
time man you know what's that called
it's the American dream right I'm the
embodiment of the American dream I lived
on five to seven continents as a frogman
Africa like villages in Afghanistan I
lived in Cosmopolitan European cities
Iraq you know all in Asia everywhere and
it's the American dream man it's not the
Argentinian dream it's not it's not the
English dream Irish it's not it's the
American dream because this is the only
place that my story could happen every
day like all the time we could win some
series
yeah yeah amazing immigrate the United
States she's a lieutenant governor of
Virginia
so that's what I think is is important
about these
growing up where things aren't handed to
you as much because you I've fought for
everything I've had everything my entire
life
and I know what that means and and then
I can assign value to that
so I'm guessing you didn't quite see
this trajectory when you were putting
some premium gas into some guy's Chevy
for 4.75 cents an hour because I worked
at Wendy's did you really yeah I worked
at Wendy's what did you do there I was
the the burger cook guy okay which I
would make burgers and it's interesting
you go to Wendy's the burgers are fresh
which means when some when eight people
walk in they make a rough guess sure you
know and they'll go put on 10 so you put
on ten yeah and if two of them don't
sell they go into a bucket and that
bucket gets turned into chili but you
know I did not know that yeah so I'm
working at Wendy's
I I you know and I knew I wanted to go
in the military
at some point at what point did the
military seem like the call actually let
me hear the worst day of this of the 17
year old vano working at
um the gas station not eating just no
food just not eating
not enough money you gotta make rent
and I gotta pay for gas for a car about
a say a 1969 Toyota Corona Corona I
wrote not a Corolla Corona it was built
in September 69 same month and year that
I was born it was red with a white
racing stripe man 500 bucks boom cash in
the batter on the barrelhead right you
got to pay for gas because you got to go
to work
you got to make rent and sometimes you
don't have money for food and what's
what's tragic Jocko is people are
getting there again in America yeah
they're they're having to make those
decisions and it's shocking so yeah not
eating was you know I mean right now
clearly that may be a good thing dude I
tell people like you know we're nine
Wheels some more of that right yeah
we're like we're nine meals away from
Anna at any point right and I'm like I'm
like 15 to 20 minutes away from me let's
be honest you gotta be like I could be a
Castaway for a while it may be a good
thing yeah so so sometimes you're not
eating you're 16 you're 17 you're still
working at the gas station at what point
do you go this ain't working check I
went out with uh buddy of mine his name
was Kurt and um
you know we're drinking beer we're in
Oregon and and uh I'm like let's join
the Marine Corps and he's like yeah I
was doing the Marine Corps oh yeah so we
got you know we get all tuned up and we
were like the best Marines for six hours
and I wake up and I call and I'm like I
do not want to join the Marine Corps and
he's like I do not want to try to make
or I go let's join the Navy he goes okay
I picked him up we went to the
recruiting office what no that was it
that was exactly as much thought that
went into it now remember now gunny was
he was a Marine
my you know the guy that I aspired to be
what made you say like you're fired up
to go to the Marine Corps six hours
later I don't think so what was what was
sobriety
that's that's what happened did you did
you understand anything about the
military you were just like hey no you
know Marine Corps that seems cool they
got cool uniforms they carry machine
guns yeah no and you know what it's
interesting if you want to I mean not to
over spiritualize things or get too
philosophical about stuff sounds like
we're about to sure there's there's been
several inflection points in my life
where it's just kind of like you know
throw your chips to the wind and see
what happens
because at that point I was going
nowhere and I realized that you know I
guess uh alcoholics call it an epiphany
you know that you have this moment
and um
I kind of had that moment where I
realized
this is just not I don't want to live
this way the rest of my life right and
so there had to be a change and you know
how do you change like that I'm a high
school dropout I couldn't get accepted
you know any of that stuff right
um and it just really it was an epiphany
so I joined the Navy did you have to get
your GED how'd that work I got they gave
me six months to get a GED I was offered
three different programs statement
apprenticeship firm and apprenticeship
and Airmen apprenticeship okay that's it
there's no other options
and so just so everyone knows what that
means that means menial labor the the
lowest jobs the most menial jobs that
you can get in the Navy all right those
three jobs in the three different broad
departments in the Navy yeah straight up
media labor and um so I just like okay
you know I signed on I got stationed at
Naval weapons station Concord hold on
yeah so sorry you said it took you six
months to get to get your G36 months
they're like so I wanted to dab the
delayed entry program yep they said
what's your active duty you have six
months to get it oh okay so I went to my
first Duty station Naval Weapon Station
what year was this 1988 1988 man they
were hurting for some people then listen
dude Reagan wanted the 600 chip Navy
that's right you could like where's here
give me this tarantula so you could like
wipe the blood off a knife you just stab
somebody with and they're like don't do
that again and they'll let you know come
on in right but and now you know that's
something I was alluding to earlier is
that you know our standards now people
have not face this adversity and so
we're taking we said all these
prerequisites for guys to go to
different programs especially
specialized programs that you know
they're kind of unrealistic but yeah so
um I would drive up over the Benicia
bridge I can't remember the name of it
mayor Island and I would take classes
and I took my GED and you know got that
within the six months so you're 18 when
you actually get in the Navy I was 18
actually turned 19 in boot camp okay
you're so you turned 19 in book how's
boot camp
you know what I mean it was just boot
camp it was a shock to your system were
you like no I was not one of these guys
we totally happy to be there that's
three odds and a cot man you know you
like food yeah I mean yeah apparently uh
oh everyone understands what you're
saying
um so yeah I mean it was just what
you're doing and um
but that's kind of how I live my life I
approach it like this is what we're
doing and so let's just do it let's
crack on and let's do it the best that
we can and that really paid off in Buds
and I'll tell you a story though so in
order to get to buds right I joined the
Navy I'm working on how do you know
about the seals at this point I had no
idea they like yeah they wasn't like hey
Derek check this out by the way you can
never do this you're going to work and
talk about because you're a scrub you
know that's essentially what it said so
I cleaned toilets and painted see so you
get done with boot camp where do you get
stationed we have a weapon station
Concord Concord California it's closed
now okay there's a ammunition station
you show up there you're in E1
[Music]
you're a very low ranking individual
right but I still had this sort of um
you know I mean it was a smart alec you
know to put it mildly you're a smart
alec at 50 how old are you 53 you're a
smart Aqua 53 when we worked together
you were a smart alec at 40 something so
I can only imagine it was even worse
when you were here's the difference Jaco
I I have now earned it I've earned it
when I was a young man I I didn't I was
a brass young man and I didn't have
humility
and so I decide to go to core school
because I had a friend who worked at the
clinic and um I wanted to go do that so
I had to work for
six months eight months or whatever
after hours I struck for a rate
um for all your civilians that's um
applying for a job did you apply for the
job as Corman I was a right so I made
bm3 both since May 3rd class decorating
um and then I went and became a corpsman
but so here here was the turn a quarter
inch shackle turned my life around and
that's a I'm shock I don't know how to
describe that it's a Fastener it's the
fastest like nautical metal thing right
and uh so I was standing on the fan tail
of the ytb that's young uh yard Tugboat
828 kataha Casa all yard tugboats in the
Navy are named after American Indian
chiefs in case you're wondering so I'm
on the fan tail that's the back of the
boat
and uh I get beaned in the back of the
head with a quarter inch shackle
and I turn around and there's nobody
there
and I'm like
if I don't change my ways these people
will kill me
and that really opened
that was a reality check and I don't
encourage you know changing people's you
know behavior modification through
violence but I'm just telling you my
story
and um I was like wow I need to
you know change my ways now and I did
and then I got to to core school so you
apply you have to apply to go to core
school oh yeah yeah so I worked at the
clinic on base after hours and it was
like six or eight months got it and I
had to take a series of tests I did all
these um the general military trainings
I did a whole bunch of Correspondence
courses like the NATO handbook on
surgery and all these things I did which
is a course for Physicians I ordered it
used to be able to order all these books
for the Navy and I just have an act for
it you know I'm I know I seem like a
goofball in them but I'm actually a
knack for nerding out and studying on
something yeah and passing tests yes I
had been reading since a kid you know
what I mean it wasn't it wasn't strange
to me to Garner Knowledge from the
written word
and so being able to read things absorb
information and then
take things from disparate sources
combine them together to understand the
best way to do things is just something
I'm I'm just good at it you know it's
intuitive to me I don't have to work at
that so you apply to go to core school
right and then I get accepted
and I put everything I owned in the
entire world on the back of my
motorcycle and drove like everything
drove from Concord California to San
Diego and checked into core school here
how long is core School
11 weeks I think I mean that was a while
ago Dude and they didn't even have core
school here anymore and you still
haven't heard about the SEAL Teams yet
no so that Revelation must be coming
okay so there was uh
three guys that joined the Navy to be
seals one's name is Rodney unfortunately
he was killed working for the CIA after
he got out of the teams he graduated
another one seems Andy he did I don't
know X minor years got out and the other
one's name is Jeff and Jeff didn't make
it to buds anyway they're like hey you
know I'm going to be this is at core
school this is at core school okay and
uh they're all like you know and I'm me
and uh I'm like What's the seal stuff
like well you have guns and planes and
boats and you know fast cars I'm like
well I'll go do that and they're like
you can't just say I'll go do that and I
go well why not why can't you just say
I'll go do that so I was kind of mocked
a bit and then you had at that point
three chances to take this screening
test did you do the same thing what
class are you 177 okay so I was 184. and
so remember you had three chances oh no
here yeah you're an easy weren't just
yeah yeah but just did it in boot camp
oh because they they let you do that
yeah yeah
I didn't boot camp past yeah so I failed
this twice and back then like you failed
the street times you're out we don't
want to see you again you're dead to the
world right get out of here this is
while you were Corman this is why I was
in core School formula to buds to get a
bill to budget and fail once what'd you
fail swim okay I didn't know how to do
the side stroke yeah I've been swimming
since I was you know a kid I just don't
know how to do a formal struggle right
so I failed this thing twice and they
started renovating the barracks which is
the not the oldest but second oldest
building in San Diego at the naval
hospital that was our Barracks so they
moved us to 32nd Street the Navy based
on there and by now this is this is a
personal thing at this point because of
the push-up sit-ups run I don't know if
you did dips anyway crushed holos
pull-ups right Crush all of them can't
do the swim so I go to the pool there's
a nine-year-old kid in the pool
and he's doing the side stroke
and I'm like hey dude can you show me
because there was no mentoring yet
remember that just like go do this yeah
no mentoring I go hey man can you show
me how to do that a nine-year-old kid
he's like yeah
grab an apple pull the Apple down get it
with you they're gonna throw the Apple
away grab another Apple oh just keep
doing that the cat this kid was good
right that's a side stroke so you know I
did it past test
that quarter inch shackle
gave me the humility which was the thing
that I was missing as a young man to be
able to ask a nine-year-old kid
how to do the side stroke
and then somebody Huck that thing at you
this shackle yeah and they just didn't
give a [__] no listen man I mean right
in the back of the head
and then so you know the the teleports
are actually beautiful boats this big
wide fantail in the back and then
there's a the o1 level which is where
the um the coxins flat is you know the
Wheelhouse
um you know clearly they were up there
and
so I I've had the ability Jocko and I
think you have also an echo I'm
unfortunately I don't know you well
enough hopefully I will I don't whatever
you're gonna say I doubt he has
um there's there's people in the world
that have the ability to understand when
they're taking part in history or where
things are significant to the point
where that you should modify your
behavior well that's what I think one of
the key points about this is um a lot of
times when you get hit in the head with
a shackle
you look at everyone else and say I
can't believe they're doing this to me
I can't believe that someone you get mad
you get mad at the Navy you get mad at
the people on your Tugboat you get mad
at everybody else
right when what you actually need to do
is say well there's only one person I
control and that's me I'm the one that
got myself on the back of this Tugboat
I'm the one that got myself around these
bunch of people I need to do something
to get out of here I need to take
ownership of my life and move forward
and that's a huge difference and it's a
huge difference in mentality that can be
the difference between staying where
you're at I mean you obviously did the
same thing at the gas station at some
point you're like you know being hungry
sucks and I could be mad at my paycheck
at the gas station I'd be mad at my car
for using gas
or I could say hey I put myself in this
situation and I need to get myself out
of it where's the recruiter so that's a
that that's the thing that you're
talking about when you explain that to
me I think yeah well that's gonna have
that's the difference between moving
forward moving up improving your your
station in Life or staying where you're
at yeah and if you have the the
wherewithal to do things
um
you should do things I mean some things
are just that simple you can sit around
and hang out or you can can you can
continuously try to improve yourself
yeah and uh so I've got friends like
that one of them I got to give a shout
out to Mike Hammer his dude up in our
village in Butternut is just always
doing things they just got into sailing
with his family now so he sails on this
is a farmer who now has this big boat
sailboat that he runs his kids around
Lake Superior on because he is always
him and Liz she's just wonderful
um have always kept their eyes open
and when people had their head down we
talked about that earlier with your
posture you just don't see the world
around you and um I made a conscious
decision to not do that I made a
conscious decision to be part of the
equation
and I think more people
they should understand that like I I
mean not to get overly political here
but I talk to people I'm like hey
um you know you can go outside and you
can stare at a hill
it doesn't matter how long you look at
that the cavalry's not coming over the
hill they're not coming
you know it's you you are the cavalry so
when you care enough about something you
got to understand you are the person
that can affect positive change and so I
Empower people and I go talk to them I
go look man we always talk about the
guys that jumped in the same area glease
or one of the beaches in Normandy or the
Marines in kaisan and Vietnam or in the
Argonne forest and in World War One
we think about them as these people that
at the singular point in time when
they're when their country our country
needed them they stood up
and they they bodily entered into
something knowing that they may not come
back alive
in the same vein
that's who the people that care about
the United States are now now I hope to
God they never have to get involved in
physical combat we've both been there
and it's it's a horrible thing and War
should be horrible so people don't want
to get engaged in it but they're doing
that now and they have to show courage
because courage is contagious we've seen
this a lot of people out in the civilian
world have not and I'll give them an
example that people can understand
because it's kind of funny
during the lockdown
there's it's uh I think it's 323.10 is
the statute in the Wisconsin State law
that says that the governor has the
ability to exercise emergency Powers
it's like a 30-day window so I'm like
okay check I don't know what's going on
it's like your dudes in combat you're
like go do this it's like well sir I
think we should have a you know right no
emergency situation boom got it right
but then when that emergency
um ends or the legal Authority ends then
it's time to challenge authority the
same person that is a law-abying citizen
right that's your duty to follow the law
when you're in a crisis situation it's
the same person that says no when that
expires
that is that is your duty as a citizen
is to stand up for what's anyway so
um this lockdown's going on
and I'm like I'm I'm no longer complying
because the the legal Authority has
expired I will not do this I'm not so go
to Walmart because I'm a smelly you know
dirty Walmart Shopper I am and I don't
have a mask on and someone recognizes me
they have a face shield and a mask on
and dude looks at me and he's like
what are you doing I go I'm not
complying
and he said well I'm not either and he
takes the stuff and throws it into his
cart in Walmart
and uh courage is contagious he didn't
die immediately no but listen don't get
me wrong
um you know I had coveted twice and it
was horrible
and a lot of people died from it and if
you want to wear a mask right now wear
it I mean 100 if you want to wear a mask
and a face shield you want to wear
gloves you want to hand sanitize and all
that stuff that's your ability as an
American citizen to choose the way you
want to live your life and now
everybody's coming around the CDC just
said that people should be able to
choose so they should have been able to
choose back then I wrote an op-ed in
like April of 2020 called Freedom over
fear and it laid it out like you got a
pick
because you can't have both what's your
book um
extreme ownership well there's a bunch
of them I caught about leadership but
you talk about fear and stuff right
Mikey the dragons the kids book okay
mind killer right you can't function if
you're terrified
so
I think it's just a different way of of
thinking about how we should interact as
Citizens and so you want to do that
stuff go ahead I'm just not going to I
will not join you but I won't mock you
either because it's your choice
all right speaking of choices you choose
to figure out how to swim from this
nine-year-old kid now you pass your test
my test and you're going to buds I go to
butts I did you do you have any clue
about buds of this girl absolutely
nothing and and again
that's why I succeeded so I do it
184 and graduated with 24. Neil Roberts
yeah first guy killed in Afghanistan
we've got our opposite team two of them
yeah okay so we had our arms over each
other's shoulders graduating from butts
I mean he's a great man call him Fifi
yeah yeah super guy but so I got there
and I'm like I don't know what to do
here and I show up at like you go to a b
brights
so you got your pants you know that you
can stand up by themselves because
they're starched like seriously that's
not a joke you can stand them up and um
so it's like I pay all this money to
have these things done and I go down
I'm not gonna I don't know what his
first name is I'll just call him C
that's the first letter of his last name
I don't embarrass the guy you know and
uh it's like four in the morning I'm
wearing this uniform and I'm walking
like uh what is that Pillsbury dough
Burger anyway or gingerbread man or
whatever and um this guy comes up to me
he looks me up and down this is an
instructor no this is a fellow student
okay he looks me up and down he goes
you're not gonna make it like Whisperer
and I'm like
well what do I do now I just spend all
this money for these uniforms like do I
get a refund or you know do I leave and
so I'm like all right well I guess I'm
not gonna make it and so I go to class
and you know one thing leads to another
and uh it's very difficult SEAL training
in case you haven't read a book or
anything but
um and then it occurred to me I mean I
actually have them again another one of
these epiphanies when I understand
exactly what the deal is
um we're sitting on the beach where PT
and we're looking in towards the
compound so the oceans at our back and
the instructor
um he's looking out to see and we're
exercising
and it starts to rain which is bad you
know but you'll get through it and then
it starts to lightening and hail
it's like a storm it's a rare rare
recursion for San Diego exactly so
working on that Tugboat moving
ammunition
when it's their hero I can't remember
it's oh yeah hero conditioner right
right that's when there's electricity
stop stuff there you got to stop things
will blow up and so um
uh I'm thinking wow this is bad we're
staying on the beach you know the only
thing we don't have is a golf club
holding up there and the instructor he
goes and halt you know and buds that's
not like smoking if you got him you're
standing at rigid attention he runs into
the compound I'm like well God you're
going to get us off this beach
we gotta get out of here it's a
lightning storm and uh he comes running
back out and he has a dive mask on
and I'm like oh I get it
this is the contract
so my part of the contract was I'm going
to show up here every single day
and do everything I possibly can to meet
your standard my instructor not my
standard your standard and his part of
the contract was he's going to show up
every single day and make sure that I
adhere to his standard
and it was like a light bulb appeared
above my head so it's just raining so
hard that he needed a dive mask because
he couldn't see if we were performing
the functions to his standards Jack
so that was that was it I'm like I get
buds at this point well how deep were
you in the buds a couple weeks that was
ptrr oh fourth place it didn't close up
yet so when I started there was guys
with like sandbag so they're like you
have to do the
oh course and I'm just making up these
numbers now in 10 minutes and then it
had to be 9 30 and you know you had this
progression right so they would do it
just passing on purpose because I knew
they were better athletes than me and I
took the opposite approach I was like
I'm gonna get up every single day and
try as hard as I can for everything I do
like every single thing I do and then
I'm gonna get better
I'm not gonna
stay the same
you know or decrease I will get better
and I know I can do this because there's
somebody wearing a trident making me do
it so it's possible and so I did that
that's how I got your buds and I swear
man third phase out of town we're flying
back
and I was certain that plane was gonna
crash
because there's no way I could be
graduating you know what I mean what was
the
what do you remember about like hell
week was hell week a challenge for you
um it was but I was a broker leader
because I was an E5 oh you're an E4 I
wasn't E4 Wheeling some heat dude yeah
and um I've found yeah I have found
personally that when you are in a
leadership position and you have people
that you need to be concerned about then
you're putting their care above your own
which I've done my whole life so that
was just you know something that you do
that it actually makes the time go by
better because you're not worried about
yourself you're not you're not focusing
internally you know this is hard I'm
freezing and you know I'm chafed and
whatever you're looking out for your men
and you're like oh you get this but
you're like this person is having a bad
time
and what can I do from my position to
make this better for them so that we can
accomplish the mission
and you know if someone couldn't make it
in buds people are like oh you should
help them and carry them along I took
again the opposite approach if this
person can't get through buds
and we're going to carry them through
buds what are they going to be like when
they get to SEAL Teams
so there's
you can take that to an extreme if
somebody was having a bad day you help
them out but if someone was consistently
performing below par I don't want them
around no
so for me hell week was uh I mean very
challenging
but at the same time I think it was
easier for me than any of the guys in my
boat crew because they they were more
focused they were more focused on them
getting through this and I was more
focused on getting us through it I liked
Howie because there's nothing that could
fail like everything else because I
wasn't good at anything I wasn't I
wasn't good at running I wasn't good at
swimming it was good to go of course I
was going to tell everybody that you're
always I was always like if you know
this could I could fail this swim I
could fail this round I had to just put
out so hard
but hell week was like oh we just got to
finish bro I could do that you just not
quit that's that's my game you want to
play that game that's my game no sleep
and no quitting I'll that's my game if
there was a Pro Sport I'd be doing good
at that sport yeah so hell week for me
was fun what what about the water was
the water all good for you pool comp and
all that stuff yeah I so I failed pool
comp the first time me too what do you
know why I failed Pokemon for the first
time because I forgot the end of the
brief what was the end of the brief kiss
the regulator Ascent yeah what'd you do
just I just sat there
so I did the whole everything yeah and I
just forgot the end of the brief just
the regulator and ascent and uh McCarthy
was my instructor oh yeah yeah sure and
he pulls me out of the pool you know
he's like what is wrong with you I don't
know what do you mean he goes dude if
you had just kissed the regulator and
ascended you'd be fine and I was like oh
check Raj that's the end of the brief
um so no the water worker's fine I did
struggles swims but um like passing
swims you're a small swimmer yeah dude a
nine-year-old taught me how to do the
side stroke like two weeks before I went
to butts so in fact yes I was a slow
swimmer
actually about three months before I
went to buds because I they're in that
interim period from core school to going
to buds I worked at the naval hospital
and I collected dirty linen so awesome
but I also
so the the linen collection shop at
Balboa Naval Hospital I don't know if
it's still there was down in the
basement right next to the morgue and I
was like I'm gonna go to Bud's training
and I should understand more about
human physiology because I'm going there
and so I would go do it's like Wednesday
morning's guy named Braswell
he was the autopsy instructor so I would
go
do these autopsies you know I would
stand there I finally worked my way up
to weighing organs but just to really
truly understand physiology because you
read that in a book and you can do a
cadaver lab and that sort of stuff but
when you have
um you have someone that is newly
deceased you have a much better
understanding of how things truly work
in your body it was a fascinating
experience actually there's an
interesting little uh off ramp we just
took into the morgue well I mean
right and then I went to uh the 300 F1
program down in San Antonio Texas after
I graduated from buds uh and then I went
finally after uh two platoons at Team
Four in South and Central America and
then Bosnia Herzegovina I finished the
18 Delta course of which I was the
distinguisher undergraduate from my
class boom you know why because I didn't
want to go
because I was Frogman and I want to take
six months off to go work with the Army
going to school anymore I want to stay
in a platoon right that was my thing if
you're a CEO of course you're being a
platoon yes and if you're in a platoon
you should be at War
that's it you know the and God bless
them the guys that do 27 years that
trade at marops instructors you know
thanks that's so no one else has to do
that but you get the deal the seals
natural environment is combat cut dry
period over
um but yeah so uh I didn't want to go
and I'm like Army Special Forces guys I
have so many SF friends you know they're
good dudes I'm like how do I beat them
aha academically right so that's they're
very serious about academics that course
was really hard that was a hard course I
didn't go through it but I remember you
would kick guys asses right so
when I graduated the commander had to
give me their Commander's Excellence
going you love that it was just like
their hand is shaking you know
so and it was just very very interesting
and if you're going to do your job do it
the best you can yeah yeah that's just I
mean everyone should take that approach
to life if you're gonna have you ever
seen this um it's a documentary called
uh hero love sushi
I have not seen it but I I know about it
I started watching it bro and honestly
it didn't it didn't really grab me and I
don't I don't have a bunch of time to be
watching movies that aren't getting me
out of the gate and it just didn't do it
I'll I'll get to it at some point I
think when I'm older like maybe 65 70
I'm Gonna Roll into that because I've
heard it's great you know what I think I
was totally focused and he has the most
popular sushi place in the world and
there's all the hard to get to and it's
this little Shack on the side of the
road or whatever a really small thing
and he's the best in the world what I
got out of all of that is that you have
the attention span of a gnat
no so this guy is talking about
um you don't you don't have to be proud
of your job
but you have to be proud of your work
interesting that's the whole crutch that
movie that's why it's so fascinating and
you gotta get to that you know so you
can be doing anything just do it the
best you can oh that's that's 100 and by
the way that's the way if you don't like
your job the way out of your job is to
do the job to the absolute best of your
ability that's how the way to stay in
your shitty job that you don't like is
to not perform well at it and it's not
going to work out well for you to stay
in that job or you need an even worse
job right uh so you're flying back from
San Clemente Island which means you're
graduating from Buds and you get
stationed where do you what do you get
Seal Team for did you pick East Coast I
picked Seal Team Four and this is why
because Seal Team 4 was the only Seal
Team I was aware of that had been in
combat since the Vietnam War and just
like we just talked about man a seals
natural environment is combat so I I put
that as my first choice because I
thought that was the team that has the
highest probability of entering into
combat yep and so that was in in Panama
this is that was Panama's 1989. so now
it's
1991 October 23rd 1992 I graduated from
bud so we've got 93-ish or whatever so
the uh
at the time that was it man and that was
gonna show yeah and and at the time
operations and all that stuff yeah at
the time the seal teams were
geographically oriented correct and so
that meant that different teams had
different geography that they covered
and Seal Team Four at the time covered
Central and South America which means
every Spanish-speaking person in the
SEAL Teams went there immediately
and there was there was things going on
down there there was the counter drug
stuff there was revolutions going on so
there was right that sounded like a good
place for you the way you looked at it
that's where you wanted to go yeah and I
tell you what you were smarter than me
you know I want to go to Seal Team one
because I thought we were going to nam
I was like Bro Team One Vietnam there's
got to be stuff going on you know I went
to Vietnam in 1998. well that's awesome
and on the recovery missions going task
forceful account yeah
um yeah man so I went to Team Four I did
uh two platoons there how was it when
you showed up at Team Four because
that's the other thing at Team Four and
that was a guy that had a bunch of
friends that went to Team Four and Team
Four was like an awesome team at that
time yeah Team Four was is the East
Coast or was the East Coast equivalent
of Team five
much more relaxed and but super super
professionals like so we would you would
do I think six weeks of land Warfare at
picket and then you'd go down to Panama
and you spent your first month and a
half living in the jungle doing I
actually did that trip from Team One did
you really yep we went down there and
did 34 days or something out in the day
right so you seriously know what you're
doing yeah
um and I really I really appreciated
that a lot and that's why I I
volunteered to go to trade at
because I was not satisfied with our
land Warfare training I thought it was
completely inadequate
um coming from that background at Team
Four so I did those two platoons and
then here's what was your job corpsman
and intelligence oh that's right you
were a medic that's medic and Intel so I
did April Tunes as uh Corman and a medic
and I mean you don't really do that
anymore once you become a chief it was
still my specialties my forte and how
were those deployments
they were very interesting I mean
um I got my first so this is like 94
you're going on your first deployment or
90 94 95 so 94.95 I got um I got my
first Navy Achievement medal when I was
in stt at the time
which is interesting I told you because
I got my second down on my my first
deployment the first one was because
some guy got shot at a basketball court
outside of a grocery store in Virginia
and I went and saved his life which you
know as you do and then
um there was another terrific accident
so I was a new guy but I'm like I stick
to my guns right and I paid the man for
it several times but I would insist on
bringing my medical gear back to we were
staying like four different condos in
Salinas Ecuador
and I would insist of packing up all of
my medical gear and taking them back to
my room every night after training and
like new guy we wanna and I'm like I
don't care you know
tune me up if you want but I'm gonna
have my stuff
like two o'clock in the morning I'm kind
of big thing this this car was driving
and uh they lost control and hit a
cement telephone pole
you split the car in half and shot
bodies all over the street
so I was like holy beanbags and um I had
all my stuff
and made the Naval Base this is written
in this little Navy achievement middle
and um made the Navy base reopen their
clinic and had all my stuff and all the
guys oh my God but I just I miss
sometimes being around seals because
they just perform you're like bam they
can be sitting around doing something
they're on it so everybody has that you
know nascent medical training and they
all just performed I'm like this this
this gotta check we saved everybody's
lives
um so that was part of the reason that
this um you know deployment was so
terribly interesting uh and then
96 rolls around 95 96 rolls around and
um
they the the war was going on in bosniah
so is this now your second platoon this
would be my this wasn't even a platoon
I'd done two platoons and this was like
kind of an augment thing it was really
weird so they're they're
trying to figure out a way to implement
the Dayton Accords that were signed in
1995 after storm 95 which is a Croatian
offensive that kicked the serbs back so
they signed this date and Accords and
they're trying to figure out how to
implement them prior to that there was a
program called The Joint Commission
observers and those were tier one guys
that were going in and you know doing uh
jtac stuff and whatever
and uh so this transitions to how are we
going to maintain this presence on the
ground so they transition from the tier
one guys to Theater South and SF had
this mission
and they wouldn't let us do it were you
around what were you doing so 1990 what
year is this 96 96 I was in training
sell at Seal Team One okay so you
remember the jco stuff for guys gonna go
to Bosnia all right so they come back on
the grinder at Team Four and which it
was just part of a compound you know I'm
on the east coast and uh they're like
okay SF can't man this Mission we're
gonna let seals do it so everyone was
like
you know yeah we're going to war we're
all excited right and they go we're
taking E7 and above no and I'm like I'm
gonna E5 yeah
so I'm like come on man so everybody
goes to the language lab signs up this
this is something that I learned and I
think I'm I'm not sure I hope that I'm
wrong but I see the military going back
to the way it was in the 90s
politically and all this stuff right I
mean I I do believe we are auguring in
the Department of Defense is broken
right now so everybody goes and signs up
on you know like this legal pad
and then they call them in rank you know
one the next and next next and
everyone's like well actually I gotta
mow my lawn well my daughter's in soccer
well you know and they work their way
down
uh they get down to E5 Derek
so some of the guys that signed up
weren't really one you understand this
concept when you're standing in a group
and you need to be like oh going to work
yeah I'm a seal that's great and I get
really excited about it but then when
you get them on one-on-one they don't
want to be there you know I mean they
joined the Canoe Club they want to work
out and all that stuff that that
transcends all Spectrum you know that's
not unique to seals
so they get down to me
and that's freaking crazy dude right
and so I going to see my CNC
um his name is Perry
total redneck awesome guy
and he goes oh van Norton what you doing
I go Mass chief
General Patton had to petition General
Pershing as the second lieutenant to be
included on his expedition during the
Mexican-American War
and he goes you try to tell me some kind
of GD General Patton he did not
abbreviate that and I said no
Massachusetts but I'm telling you my
bags are packed right now and I can
leave in 10 minutes
he's like beat it I know at this point
are you married yeah you're married when
did you meet your wife in San Diego
right before uh right after I no right
before I went to buds we got married
right after buds got it so I spent
I was a seal for just under 22 years I
spent 16 years away from home
so I took every single training trip I
went to every single school I could
because again
you have to find if you're doing
something do it
don't and that's a Biblical principle
you know be either hot or cold if you
lukewarm I will spit you out that's in
the Bible man so if you're doing
something do it
and so I got every single qualification
I possibly could so in case something
came up I would be the one selected to
do it to go defend my country
I mean I live my life that way right how
fast did you have kids do you have kids
did you have kids
by the time we got to Team Four we had
two kids
damn yeah I have eight grandchildren
impressive gosh you're so
all everything you're about being a
granddad
you're not even close to how cool it is
seriously they're just wonderful but
yeah so um I went on that deployment it
was very interesting
um I remember
so we had these different houses I
didn't live in a base my house was
whiskey 40. so I was a multinational
division Southwest I worked for a guy
named John Cass was a British Colonel
reported to a Special Operations Command
control element sock C that was in
banyuluca a guy named uh repass Mike
repass was a major at the time I wound
up working for him again when he's a
two-star in Germany it was really cool
but uh we went into Sarajevo we fly in
we went to another John commission
Observer house and the SF guys and kind
of like slowly get you in there's two
seals there in my house when we moved
out to uh bubano sending the town we
lived in
um and then like seven to nine SF guys I
get up every morning I drive out and I
talk to all the military and uh local
political figures and police figures and
it was the mission was to provide a
ground truth about what's going on
and um
I had so much responsibility as an E5
like to plan these missions and go out
and I had like a pistol and a butt pack
with one other seal with a pistol and a
butt pack and you're going out
and you know talking to these people
that just want to kill you
and the level of um
it's the Yiddish term would be hudspa
you know you've got to get out there and
I'll give you this example man so we go
up to Banya Luca to the 117th vrs that
is a Serbian military unit
I wanted to go check in with these cats
and it's kind of on it's sort of on a
little Hill but back then you for satcom
you had to have the right look angle and
Asthma remember
okay yeah right you know you get it
these other people you know where's my
phone you know I can talk to
anyone anywhere right so back then you
had to like boom I had to get the
satellite so I had I do the the math
problem I look at where I'm going I
realized that I'll have to point this
this antenna into a mountain and I'm not
getting comps and there were no cell
phones right so I I understand that you
know it's just me and my buddy Nick
so we go up there and um I'm late or
excuse me we're on time this guy's not
there his name was uh chulich colonel
chulich
we walk in and there's this dude
standing right there who has got Rosy
Cheeks like mine a huge white beard
fatter belly than me and I'm like oh my
gosh this guy looks like Santa Claus and
I start chocolate so this is a Serbian
base remember NATO had been bombing
disturbs and they are yeah it wasn't 64
days or something right they want no
part of us and so they are not happy
and direct what are you talking about in
my turret name his name is zoren
azuminidich
because he was fat and like Zircon like
Orca okay right so zorin they're like um
he's starting to worry and and uh
they're like what are you laughing at I
go all right well let's look like this
is going down right now you know and
there's like 400 serbs here and two of
us we have
31 rounds of nine millimeter with us
like that's it so I go okay hey in the
United States we have a guy his name is
Santa Claus and you look just like him
that's what we're laughing at and they
start laughing they go oh they're
serving Orthodox they have St Nicholas
they're like that's what we call them
too
I was like okay you know and then so we
sit down at this table I hope yeah that
really happened this is an international
incident because you were laughing at
Santa saying Help there right it gets
more bananas so we're sitting at this
huge table and uh chulich is supposed to
show up at the head of the table and
whatever you use an interpreter you put
them in between you and whoever you're
talking to right so they should just be
a conduit
for language
so he's sitting there this guy's just
late late we're sitting there drinking
it's a just a plum brandy it's an
excellent actually in France they call
it odv Water of Life maybe it's a mirror
belt in case you're wondering but um so
this guy finally shows up
and my my radios in this rucksack
and the studies dressed like a Russian
mothy guy this is the dude that just
showed up the colonel who should have
been there like three hours before he
was in bangaluka goofing off anyway
black leather jacket hair slick back and
he's like
you know uh serbians are great warriors
I'm like yeah they are because uh
serbians cap
um Europe say from the Ottomans for 300
years I'm like yeah
serbians could kick NATO out of here
anytime we want I look at them I go
you see that radio right there you keep
that up I'm gonna rain fire from the sky
on you in 10 minutes
is that clear and zorin remember I'm
gonna eat five dude talking this yeah
Serbian Colonel so Zorn is there he's
just like like instant sweat like he
just ate uh a ghost pepper
and he's like uh Echo Zorn you tell him
exactly what I said right now or you're
out of here and he's like
okay
you keep that up he's gonna rain fire
from the sky on you in 10 minutes and
Juliet was like what I meant to say was
the serbians and NATO can have an
effective working relationship to make
sure that we secure piece in boxing like
a check
so we get done with the meeting it went
really well after that
we get back in the car insurance like
Derek you know where you're at and I go
yeah I'm cool to camp
he goes do you know what happened to
cool account I'm like no so what I
failed to notice is that like all these
buildings were freshly painted and
everything was nice they've been
destroyed destroyed by NATO
so when I told that guy I'll be raining
fire from the sky and you know in 10
minutes
he understood what that meant
yeah terribly interesting yeah that's
crazy that that's when I was at E5 dude
yeah
it's crazy the amount of responsibility
you can get yeah we had so in the
military
um
I was one of the guys that ran the six
platoons this mission was Declassified
in like 2009 so we protected the top six
Iraqi officials and during the election
cycle I had this guy named Ibrahim Al
Jafari so that was a patentee of this
time so this is team one no this would
be team five
so I was a team four and then I went to
18 Delta I went to team one okay so I
wouldn't pay competition all right so
hold on slow down a little bit so you're
you're at Team Four you get done at Team
Four correct and you get done with the
spazzing deployment which is an awesome
deployment for back then it's like you
were it was the only War we had the the
this most stoked you could possibly be
at that time
and then you get forced to go to 18
Delta against your will right but you go
down there and kick ass correct graduate
number one guy in the class that is
correct
now you now what happens okay
so I was supposed to go to damek
you know how you have sea daddies and
they lay out your whole plan for you
yeah and the Corman detailers for same
as Tom he's a very good guy I don't know
where he's at now So the plan was for me
to finish 18 Delta and at that point
they were only taking 84.91 so that's
the senior level this is for your
audience so it's 8492s that's the basic
you know Special Forces medic and then
the the full graduate of the army
Special Forces medical sergeants course
that time the Dam Neck was only taken
these guys
so that's why I had to go to 18 Delta
Tom sets all this up
but then I'm sitting there this remember
this is 98 99ish
and I had been gone for the five and
plus years I was at Team Four and then
Sarah and I had three kids at the time
she's a San Diego native
and I really felt horrible you know what
I mean because I'm a husband and a dad
and all this stuff and her family's
still here they're wonderful
um
so I was like you know what I'm gonna
ask to get assigned to the West Coast so
that I can continue to work as a frogman
as I should
but you'll have more support network
around me or around her sorry so
um
we're sitting in this meeting you know
Tom pulls all the corner and where do
you want to go where do you want to go
and he's asking him you know East Coast
West Coast whatever and he looks at me
and he's like you know just skipping
over me and I said West Coast and he was
like what yeah West Coast man he's like
check goes around everybody I put in
five
because that was the Seal Team Four then
I put in three then I put in one now
this is the person that decides where
you are going like it is up to him where
did I go team one yeah he was so mad
and
at me personally and I mean it was a
great experience there but it was just
so different
like I got yelled at
I would say 40 times in the first two
months I was there because I had like
the wrong pair a team when did you get
there
she was he was 98 late 98 so fact was
there and you know so I left in 98. okay
so so you had just we just missed I left
I left in the spring of 98 so if you
didn't get there until I can't remember
yeah it was not I deployed in um 2000 so
whatever that cycle would be yeah so
yeah I left in the spring and idea but
yeah at that time just uh we called team
one Stalag team one because it was like
strict and it was traditional and it was
uniform inspections and haircut
inspections and all these kind of things
were going on and I loved it
yeah and well that's why you wrote a
book called like discipline equals
freedom and I didn't let's just be
really clear about that you know what I
mean yeah and it's one of those things
where you know that's where I was kind
of raised you know from a young kid to
you know that's where I've got all my
first experience and you know like you
talk about faculty faculty was like my
Legend and a like a legit friend who
looked out for me and my group of
friends we were all kind of his boys and
sure you know we worked we freaking
busted our ass and that's what yeah you
know what happened I remember you
checking out because you're there with
Chris yep yep yep
yeah that's when I was saying I I was I
was sail of the year until team one well
no yeah that was but I was the the only
E5
in history you made E5 or yeah
as an E5 which was crazy but part of
that was because fact like you know I
was worked hard for fact it worked right
for him um yeah training sound stuff
but yeah it was this very strict
environment of much more militaristic
than the other teams and I I went from
there to team two and team two was
similar right that was stopped it was
stuck no we call that style yeah it was
it was pretty stylish as well they were
they were the same Seal Team One until
team two were definitely
on the spectrum of way more militaristic
way so that's and you know what happened
at Team One a lot of guys from team one
would hated it and would go to Team five
they would go down the street team five
and just be like oh now we can like act
like humans right and be chill and so
and that would be cool that's a that's a
nice transition your transition the
opposite direction is not a nice
transition it was like I'd had the wrong
Paris it was like a matrix so Dean
Cummings who is he's a great dude I mean
he was the CMC there and uh it was
always like fan art and you know this
hat and the socks and this shoes and
whatever like so finally I go hey
Mastery now remember I've done two
platoon's one combat deployment to
Bosnia was the I I got the defense
meritory service medal as E5 was the
most highly decorated guy from my
rotation because of some other stuff
that I did there right
the undergraduate of my Army Special
Forces medical sergeants course I'm not
some new guy that just fell off you know
the buds train right I am experienced at
that point I was a journeyman seal yeah
you know what I mean not a master I was
a journeyman and finally I'm like hey
Master Chief can I get like a matrix
of what I can wear with what because I'm
not doing this on purpose I just don't
know what you'd expect me to wear every
day so PT is this and then you change it
and he was like fan art around it and I
go I'm not joking yeah and then he
realized I was sincere yeah because dude
the guy you're talking about Chris who's
like one of the biggest studs in human
history but we we were in buds together
and then we get to team one and we're
going on a run like we're new guys yeah
and he walks out for the Run he's
wearing a visor
like a like a visor like you know like I
don't know he still wears a visor we
used to cut those the hat off yeah so he
walks out with a visor on and faculty
who didn't know us at the time we're
just new guys looks at me he goes if I
see you wearing that again I'm sending
you to the fleet
like like we just got done with Buds and
he's telling him he's gonna send him to
the fleet yeah and by the way this guy
Chris is like just a total stud in in
every way he's one of those mutant
humans yeah he's incredible and he will
leave me in Iraq okay I got a cool story
about that remind me of that nice uh so
you eventually figure out what you got
to do just keep your keep from getting
your ass chewed at Seal Team One correct
uh do a paycom deployment and then Force
21 came about remember that thankfully
thankfully well thankfully and no
there's some very distinct I mean like
hardcore negative sequelae because of
force 21. the first and foremost one is
it seals don't know how to do stuff
anymore yeah I guess the the thing is at
that time it was needed it was needed
and it was lucky because if we would
have gone from the old system into what
we ended up deploying as once 911 it
would have been really it would much
harder transition but when I say seals
don't want to do stuff anymore I mean
we're Stone Cold Killers right that's
not changed I just mean like the
day-to-day sort of thing so we've lost
that
um
we've lost the ability to like learn how
to sew your own gear because people I'm
like I know how to use an industrial
sewing machine as did everybody in the
SEAL Teams because he'd make her own
stuff in the power offer things like
that how do you build a duck and whatnot
but um so what was your job in your
platoona team one
I was a corpsman so oh so yeah that's
right he's an Intel guy that's what I
did that's your thing that's just my
thing I got it but so um Force 21 comes
around and um I again I was I was
distinctly dissatisfied with the land of
warfare training that I got
at team one I I it was it was not
adequate because remember I came from
Team Four where you spent that was what
you did I mean you lived in the J and um
so I'm like there's no war going on
there's nothing I go I'm going to and
remember it was over at brown or Turner
Field what's up the uh you know next to
the EOD buildings over in Coronado
that field Turner Field or yeah Turner
Field okay so this is this is how
discombobulated this was and it's
fascinating they just put the road cones
like they put a road cone with like team
one team five team three trade at and
you would go stand behind the road cone
that's how I got to trade it I lit I
stood behind a road cone because I
wanted how they figured out how to
detail people yeah
it was it's kind of cool actually it
started cool but it was a mess and um so
I walk over to the building the Starship
you know I don't know if they're even
there anymore the one that was shared by
one and three and we started
um trade out we had like the second
floor or whatever it was I walked in an
empty room it's me and uh Jeff Green
then we're like we're it
and so I went through everybody's safes
in all of the teams and I took all of
their documentation going back to the
Vietnam War you know the the type stuff
after action reports and I Consolidated
all those things and we wrote all of the
curriculum for land Warfare and then
special reconnaissance taking the
Lessons Learned going back from our
forefathers to give us our you know
Fierce reputation
and then worked those over and over
again
but I get there we start doing that and
then
um September 11th happens
and I was down we lived in Navy housing
and I I'm like what the heck we got a
phone call from a guy named Andy Dalton
retired seal senior Chiefs wife Cheryl
just beautiful people it's wonderful
oops sorry and uh they're he's at team
too at the time and they're like turn on
your television
so we turn it on we're like what the
heck is going on
and um so I go hey honey keep the kids
home from school I do not know what's
happening I drive to the team area we
get snipers up in the building we don't
we don't know what's happening and I
remember I went with this big backboard
this big white board and I took a red
marker and I wrote War
big letters right there in that point we
had desks and everything
like War like it's on
and so from that point on I try to get
out of there
because we're at War right and uh lumpy
was a skipper there and every morning I
go in his office just like I do Perry
Bruce
Mike um okay I'm ready to go bags are
back he's like you're going to
Afghanistan when I go to Afghanistan
battle and I'm like ready to go every
morning every morning ready to go ready
to go and then we're going out to nylon
I think I was gone
talking about 290 days that year then
finally he's like okay you can go leave
me alone
so I I weaseled my way into an l o
position for The Siege sonoff and I
worked that for about a month and then I
was now working for the chief of station
in Kabul
because I identified a problem I looked
at the entire spectrum of all of the
operations that were that are taking
place
and I'm looking we were completely we
were not employed to the capacity that
we should be as seals and it's because
we didn't have assets and authorities
and all this stuff so I laid this plan
out I'm like if we tied this asset to
this person who has control over this
then we can execute the mission better
sales and I went to John
celeski Colonel saleski who's The Siege
sort of Commander I said Colonel navsoft
has not been employed to our capacity
he's like I know you know what's going
on and I said sure if we do this this
this and this and he goes sorry beat it
he was he was the finest joint Warfare
fighter I've ever worked with but I mean
repass was another one he's another army
guy unfortunately I wish I could lay out
this list of
seal Admirals I can say that about
there's a few but
yeah John was just he was amazing and uh
he's like get down there and get it on
vano what's up beat feet so we tied
together
for theater sauth the first real uh
interagency integration nice like
Biometrics remember Biometrics yes
Sirens like you know so I was there and
I was sitting around you know reflecting
because you should reflect
and I was looking at one of those charts
where it has all the people on a
targeted list and I was like we don't
know who is still around
off this list we don't know
and so I went and talked to a guy named
Jax he's still a super good friend of
mine he was the senior FBI agent in the
country and his office was right around
the corner from my down in uh Kabul at
the uh Annex
I'm not Jax how does the FBI know who
people are
after they're deceased and he's like
well you know we do fingerprints we do
all the stuff and we go okay
so how do we do that here he's like well
I don't know I mean this is a huge story
so I figured out a thing for us to be
able to
um initially fingerprint folks so the
first time this is why I am the Forrest
Gump of the SEAL Teams so the first time
that theatersoft ever used Biometrics in
Afghanistan really in the war on terror
was because I cooked up this idea with
this dude who was on the Memphis SWAT
team
and so we went out
through this very complicated series of
stuff that you see with 30 and 47s and
all night and you know big Target deck
and everything
and he had like the Johnny G-Man
you know 1930s FBI fingerprint kit the
blue suitcase with the silver Corners to
fingerprint
these you know the the enemy combatants
that were no longer around that's how
all that started
that was an incredibly
interesting thing Matt and then I rolled
back and I went to team five where I was
a potato
what year was that what year was that
they were you in Afghanistan 2003.
I left October 13 2003. I remember that
because it's the
that's when you left Afghanistan for my
first tour yeah
wait you left for Afghanistan
got it I came back so it took me
I was there for six or seven months so
you know do the math between September
11th to that point yeah
but um that's the birthday of the Navy
Jocko there you go I was not aware of
that sorry what yeah what can I say
horrible sale but
um yeah I came back then I went to uh
Team five where I was a platoon chief
so you get to team five now it's 2003 so
at this point we are full on like
everyone's going on it and to Win It
Iraq opened up right when I got back
from Afghanistan I remember when we
invaded But it was right around there I
saw it was so the plan for that was 1003
Victor so 1003 was the
the Baseline operational plan and then
the letters on the end are how many
um how many different things right so it
got down to Victor so 23 Victor was the
plan where I left and all the heavy lift
aircraft started leaving Afghanistan
when I was there and I'm like there's
only so much heavy lift aircraft I go oh
my gosh
they're going to do 1003 Victor
so me coming back I don't know exactly
the periodicity when that the actual
Invasion kicked off but I knew it was
going to happen because of the heavy
lift aircraft maybe
um so you know I'm a potential Chief and
I want to go to war with my dudes I mean
I there's one of these books written by
dick couch
that they interviewed us when I was
teaching land Warfare
and in that book I'm like he's like what
do you want to do essentially like my
goal is to become a platoon chief like
that's it that to me that's a pinnacle
of an enlisted sales job there's been an
opportunity then I was a troop Chief
later but that was you know the thing
um and then we wind up they they get
this Mission this Mission set protecting
these Iraqi dignitaries and I'm like oh
man
so I mean not that it's not important
but the war was not going well at the
time
and again I said this earlier but that
mission is Declassified in 2009 so the
top six Iraqi officials were protected
by Seal putins
then it's kind of cool they randomly
assigned NFL football teams
names that was your your call sign guess
what mine was no idea Packers oh there
you go from Wisconsin I'm like this dude
might live man like whoa so um yeah we
protected a guy he was a deputy vice
president's name is Abraham Al jafri he
was a family physician at six kids uh
fled Saddam lived in Iran wind up in
London
and um
it was a it was really
it was amazingly
uh interesting to do that mission and
all the Bros are out down you guys are
doing your gig you know and um I was
essentially I went to every
place in that country running protection
for a guy that's running a political
campaign during a war where everybody
wants to kill you yeah no it was uh it
was a miracle not just a miracle uh it
was freaking awesome work by the guys
yeah to keep the all those guys safe I
mean there was everybody wanted all the
uh well not everybody but a big number
people wanted to kill one or any one of
those people and that leadership was
kept alive yeah for how long was that
mission
because you said I was not doing I
wasn't doing anything at that point I'd
come back you know I really you know my
timing was really really good because I
know I was went up did just DA's for my
first deployment which was just awesome
as we left that mission came up right
and then when I came back it was over so
I I had awesome time being as far as not
having to do that mission it it lasted
through I mean I came back after the
elections
so again the Forrest Gump thing man
remember everybody's fingers did yeah
all right so there's a picture of this
guy who became the first democratically
elected prime minister in Iraq's history
right there's a picture of him with his
finger up there I'm standing directly
behind the camera that took that picture
no because I was responsible for his
security
um so oh back to Chris man so he he's
coming in and bliff is there and we're
rotating now right
and two really funny things happen with
them one it's a Prestige thing and so
wait so he's coming in with Team seven
well who's he coming in with your team
five must have been yeah I don't know
who it was I mean he was the chief and
and cool and Bluff was his oh I see you
know and uh so two funny things happen
there's a cultural thing in um some
Arabic countries uh Iraq being one where
um do you want to be as close to the
center of power as possible I guess
that's here in the United States too but
um
so we would run these motorcades right
uh lead limb will follow and then you'd
have uh elements ahead of you and then
behind you
so if anything happened you can skid out
on these guys get in the gunfight so
you're protecting the principal and I
talked to these guys over and over again
I'm like look
you're very important people I get that
you know you're the minister of whatever
the heck but our
Soul function
is to make sure that Echo lives
you know what I mean we're going to help
you out whatever we want Medical but
that will not be to the detriment of
making sure that Echoes a lot check so
they always try to weasel into this
Convoy and these guys had one of those
beautiful old Mercedes-Benz like the
powder blue you know I'm talking to the
big just awesome and the guy's name was
Adnan Phil he was his security chief
Phil Phil is um Arabic for pepper
because he had a real hot temper you
know and Chris is in the car with and
we're sitting there you know blazing
through Baghdad and um look in the
mirror you know it's interesting when
you're in combat
you get to that point where you see
everything
do you know what I mean like things are
happening over here and you have a full
holistic understanding of your
environment and that's really why I
think people miss being in that you know
in combat because you are completely
alive
anyway so I'm talking I'm like oh my
gosh I want a sec this guy is weasel
behind us in this powder blue Mercedes
it's all not fulfilled so I just opened
up my door like this this up armor and I
point my M4 back at him
I mean clearly I'm not going to shoot
him but I I point my M4 enemies like it
goes back to the back of the line of
this you know huge motor game and Chris
was like what just happened he actually
used to make expletives and I'm like I'm
trying to tell you these people are
going to keep doing that they're on our
side but
um it's very important
um that they understand the ground rules
that are being set here and that's going
to happen over and over again Chris
doesn't matter how hard you try they're
going to keep doing this and then the
other thing
funny we're down at um do you remember
who Tarik Aziz was I remember that name
Saddam Hussein's foreign minister the
guy with the big sunglasses okay so his
house was taken over by a guy named
Abdul Aziz Hakeem who was part of the
dala party and was right by the you
exited the green zone went over the 14th
July Branch it was like right there so
that's where all these meetings are
taking place so we had to go down there
to only take the AIC which is the agent
in charge that was the you know renamed
OIC they take him inside they didn't
want anybody else there so we've got all
these cars around and I have my car
and my body Armor's in there my helmet's
in there are my rifles in there and I
have a pistol
and we'd set up everywhere and you'd be
there for hours and hours and hours so
I'd go around checking everybody it was
you know good to go
I'm in um
Chris and Bliss Carter
and I'm like okay so if we have an
indirect attack mortar artillery
whatever
you just gotta wait a minute and see if
it develops into a complex attack
meaning so they mortar stuff and then
they can use that to make everybody go
to ground and then they can start
infiltrating you know with ground troops
so I go so if that happens and you just
wait a sec and then you punch out a
perimeter immediately so that no one can
infiltrate your lines and you got to
just you got to do it like boom this
happens go and I open up the door I hop
out and boom like right over there it's
huge explosion I go just like this and I
sit back in the car like seriously I
said just like this and I sit back in
the car wait a minute okay go and then I
realized I don't have a rifle I have my
pistol so remember that little
the green army man the medic yeah yeah
so I'm running
in Baghdad with the pestle I I started
wait where was your freaking weapon bro
it was in my vehicle which was right
next to theirs
like right there oh so you went over to
tell them what to do I was going in I
was briefing about how to handle
different attack scenarios now one time
you did the one yeah you know that
happens that's freaking awful and so I'm
like you know running to a perimeter
with a pistol in my hand I start
chuckling because I'm like I just look
absurd at this point but I'm a very good
pistol shot by the way uh and what what
it turned out that ain't gonna cut it
bro you're not gonna cut it no seriously
I know Hey listen I I think we should
discuss things worse and all you know
but um what happened was the Iraqi
police had had an A.D with an RPG so
that was not an impact that was an
outgoing yeah but they have that Moon
dust out there yeah you know so you
couldn't tell it looked like a mortar
round coming it didn't sound like a
mortar round but it it looked like one
piece of the impact
so that's my funny seal start right
there
what did you learn from a leadership
perspective on that deployment that's a
tough deployment from a different angle
because you got guys that are pissed to
be doing this job but it's a very it's a
Strategic Mission to keep these guys
alive
um I learned well I didn't really learn
it it just reinforced some things for me
um the mission always comes first no
matter what
but the and the missions America it's
not some this woke [__] these uh
Military Officers are coming up with now
sorry for swearing but that that ain't
the mission dude the mission's America
and that's got to happen every day
that's why you know my fat bald person
I'm running for congress now because the
mission is America and and America is
being failed by our leadership anyway
side note so Mission comes first and
then I also learned
to let some things roll
and and this is why we were late but so
the doctor lived in the katasia which
was a like a neighborhood right outside
of checkpoint 11. so checkpoint 11 went
from the green zone to Route Irish where
everybody's getting killed all the time
you had to drive down a mile or so
whatever buttonhook left into the kind
of sea to pick this guy up
and um so we were late and I'm like you
know frick frack frackburger you know
being a sealed sailor guy we're living
in Uday Hussein it's one of his joints
on I think it was gray wolf was the
thought there but anyway so we're late
and then boom
just massive massive car bomb goes off
right at check 111. like it was so big
it blew a car like 50 feet up on top of
a tree
and here's what happened
they knew we were going to the katasia
and this they had this huge bomb and the
traffic keeps going forward and forward
and forward and forward it finally gets
to the checkpoint and they clock
themselves off we were supposed to be in
that line
passing that would have killed the
entire platoon except for the one guy we
had working on the jock
so that was a real lesson
um yeah should you strive to be on time
sure
um but you need to make sure that if
things are going a little pinky
try to figure out why yeah I used to
have uh you know my my thing was my joke
was but it wasn't really a joke but it
kind of was you know you have no go
criteria like hey we we don't have the
aircraft cover we want that's no go or
we don't have enough vehicles or we and
I used to joke but I would serious I'd
be like no it's we have in my task we
have go go criteria which is we're going
right and we don't have aircraft we'll
call tanks we but but occasionally even
with that attitude I'd be like well okay
we don't have this we don't have that we
you know this isn't working out we
haven't talked to these people and I'd
be like the
universe is conspiring against this
operation and we're not going to do it
right so it's just like a gut feeling
where I'd like I can there's I'll cover
obstacle obstacle obstacle obstacle no
Factor no Factor no Factor no Factor no
Factor
right this there's this is this we're
not doing this well that's a function of
maturity yeah it really is
um and sometimes you just look at things
and you're like
non-starter yeah yeah and that's okay
so uh
you get done with this deployment
in Iraq in Iraq correct and then what's
your next move so that's your platoon
Chief deployment get done with that
deployment what's your next one I came
back and I'm a plank owner at what was
known as the sport activities support
activities so you're going there and the
support activity basic mission is to
gather intelligence it's like a
combination of all the ins and
um you know I just had a knack for that
too so I was one of the first five guys
you know sitting around trying to figure
this out
probably Newsome was for Skipper he's a
retired captain now he worked for the
76ers doing some stuff I have no idea
yeah but um
yeah that was a very very
um rewarding time to build something
else up from the ground
because I only built
or helped build you know this is not
clearly this is all a team effort but it
helped build the special reconnaissance
land Warfare part of trade at
and then doing that it's like the whole
team
which was which was fascinating and then
I did some deployments from that that
are not really a topic for discussion
right and how but how long did you spend
there
like three years
it couldn't have been that long actually
well I came back from Iraq
and then that was would have been 2005
or six and I think I left there and
2008 ish it's like two or three years
okay there because I went to a Special
Operations Command Europe after that
after that but then you go to seven
first
so yeah sorry because you because I know
that's when you and I really that's when
you and I crossed but I think we'd met
each other along the way at some point
right but we I didn't actually right
until
I was at trade at and you were at teams
as a troop Chief so I went from you're
right it was sport activity team seven
Special Operations Command here and then
I retired out of cincio slick so okay so
you do you're doing working with the ins
and by what you mean by that is human
intelligence signal intelligence all
that kind of intelligence gathering will
say you did that for a few years I'm not
going to talk about that here
and then you go what there you want to
see something cool keep talking going
well you're breaking stuff up I want to
show you one of the coolest pictures
ever oh okay
um because this was on uh my last
appointment from Afghanistan
check that one out
that's a winner
that picture's taken about three or four
months after the boat scene on activity
was filmed
boat seen on active hours films so
accuweather's a movie with a bunch of
seals in it right I'm in the movie
when was that filmed
that wasn't that wasn't until later it
came out in 2012 or something but that
it took like three years to film that
movie because everybody except for the
officer in the the film deployed to
combat during the filming of that movie
right what happens if someone gets
killed it's gonna wreck the movie you're
like well thanks deeply appreciate your
caring about us you're gonna have to
rewrite a script that'll take you eight
minutes because there was no script
um
yeah that was uh I think it came out
2012 so they started filming that in
2009ish because that was that was I was
working up to go to Afghanistan when
that was filmed and that so here's
here's what happened with that movie
well listen let's talk to Seal Team
seven first okay so this is that still
team seven
right so really yeah so check this out
so I am a troop Chief at Team seven and
then the super specialized Mission came
along
that I had done previously and I'm the
only one at the team that has done this
and I'm the only one with the
qualification well there's two other
guys with the same qualification as me
but I'm the only one that has actually
done this Mission working for this other
subset of people doing this stuff so the
Skipper's like I don't know what I'm
doing I mean God bless him he had no
idea he goes you can pick anybody you
want from the team and take him to go do
this so me and the guy who I won't
mention is actually right next to me in
that picture because he's still active
duty
we went through everybody's records at
Team seven I'm like you know this guy
this guy this guy this guy and then we
need comms guys and all these other
folks and we put together this little
group of folks to deploy to Afghanistan
to do this super specialized mission
that was at Team seven so I went from
being a troop chief we had uh 56 or 60.
that was after that was after you did
your troop chief that was my troop Chief
deployment so we we sent guys to balad
Iraq was not happening they're wearing
starch uniforms and they have no
magazines in their guns The Walker and
saluting people in Iraq I don't want any
part of that and then there was a small
group that went to Afghanistan to get
reattached to The Siege soda for the
first time since Red Wings happened
and then I took another group of guys
over here so my guys got farmed to balad
to do nothing a small group of them it's
Declassified now into Yemen and then we
went to Afghanistan to do this other
subset so we didn't have a traditional
yeah you know tasking to go out and and
you know at Bruiser we didn't it just
wasn't available yeah
no it wasn't so I went and did that
how'd you like being a troop chief
you know what
um it was interesting but it's not
it's not uh
it wasn't like it's Hands-On the
logistics part was you know it was more
difficult to get done
um and then you you're managing
personalities
um
you know I could I I would prefer to do
this yeah I mean I guess if your your
troop gets all split up yeah if we had a
traditional true or a traditional you
know air quotations you know 0506 Iraq
or
um if we could do like
uh O3 Afghanistan where you are
seriously getting it that would have
been much different
but in effect you know I had guys
like one of my guys
I'll give you an example of why uh
one of my guys I think I had six seals
with me so going from like 60 seals to
six but they're all like you know what
we were doing that
like driving around in thin-skinned
vehicles by ourselves during the day in
Afghanistan
and your qrf is not coming so the level
of
stress that is applied I mean it's so
much easier and you know this to go with
50 dudes and lock something down and go
in and just you know do seal stuff
and that's great and it you know we get
a lot of it's very stressful that's
really stressful
when you got to plan these things in
detail intricate and if you make one
mistake it's over and I did that for
several years
I mean it's upper division Warfare is
what I call it upper division Warfare
yeah it is totally because you have to
have a holistic understanding of all the
thresholds going from the e-lengthy
electronic warfare perspective all the
way down to how do I shoot my gun
way different than you know go that way
so when you build this picture you have
you have like a a Global Perspective
but for a local area
and you understand you have all these
triggers that if they start getting
pinged you got to bail and sometimes you
intentionally trigger them
so yeah interesting so that was troop to
troop Chief thing in a way it was
not as exciting as it should have been
but again that's the first place like I
said that's the first time that I like
remember you piding like oh yeah that's
because you know I'd seen you around and
you were an essay whatever but but
that's the first time I remember you
like we were out at Desert training and
like meeting you and hanging out and
running uh ftxs and all that stuff
having good times yeah
carrying some you were carrying some you
know some wounded men out there which I
know
[Laughter]
which uh seems to have left a mark on
some people emotionally at this juncture
I was a little bit I was a little bit
crazy when it came back so all right man
Hey listen I got it I'll tell you
something I don't know if your your
viewers understands I remember when you
came back
and you went around to teams and you
gave a brief that you called the
pressure remember that yeah the pressure
and at that point because I didn't know
you either you know what I mean you're
like some dude bad haircut probably
lifts too many weights and drinks energy
drinks you know whatever just total dime
a dozen seal this is just be honest it's
good to be the diamond in the rough
um but you gave this brief and it was
you called it the pressure and it was uh
what you're doing is you're conveying I
mean this is my perspective obviously
you wrote it uh conveying the burden of
leadership
and the fact that you truly at that
point got it
which is a lot of officers never get it
and I was watching you and I thought you
were much younger than me at the time I
don't know
but I was like this guy gets it like he
understands ramifications of poor
decision making
and things are real
and it just doesn't affect you know your
reputation as I'm a I'm a great operator
you know that it affects families
and then it affects the nation and I
understood that that's when I really got
to respect for you so I'm listening to
you see that because I could see your
heart was breaking when you're
discussing this and that you weren't
making anything up
being very genuine about leadership is
really important and we're missing that
dude we're missing that from the
Tactical strategic and operational level
throughout our country and Private
Industry and the government especially
it's terrible
so now you guys know
yeah I I I haven't given that brief in a
long time
um and I remember
thinking about it and you know on
thinking about the experiences that I
had you know when when we deployed
in potassium producer you know their
their head we hadn't lost any guys on
the west coast yet right and
you know even looking into you know we
were just talking about the workup and
you're going through the workup and like
a down man was like a a theoretical
thing a a problem-solving event that
you're gonna get and you're gonna go
through it and okay now that person gets
you know you're back to life at the end
of that training Mission and uh
obviously that's not the reality of the
situation correct and and trying to make
sure to convey that to the guys and
that's you know when I got done with
that deployment
um you know the the Admiral who I knew
was like where do you want to go and I
100 just said I want to go to I want to
go to trade at I want to go to trade at
and run training and the reason is
because first of all all the guys in my
task Unit were all gonna go right back
into another
platoon right and they were all gonna go
right back overseas into that meat
grinder and it didn't look like you know
this was in 2006 when we got home it was
still you couldn't tell when it was
going to stop right it just looked like
it was going to go on indefinitely we
saw some indications that looking in
hindsight you could see that oh that was
an indication that things were going to
settle down but you couldn't positively
identify them at the time coming home
from deployment I was like no this is
going to last we're gonna have to do
this in all these other cities it's just
going to continue everyone's going back
to this meat grinder and I want to make
sure that I can convey these lessons to
the guys that are going to go back over
there and get in it and that's what
that's that's where that came from and
you you went to trade at for the same
reasons I did but six years later yeah
yep it was to pass on those lessons and
get things headed in the right direction
combat survivability of seals 100 and
that's why you know we're out at
nylender we're out at the
the urban training sites and it was like
you know I I remember feeling I see a
guy like in in an urban environment
standing in the middle of the street and
I would literally have a sick to my
stomach not when I'd see a guy standing
in the open this isn't training right
and I'd you know go over and be like you
know yeah go find cover because you're
waiting for the guy to get shot and
that's a horrible feeling
and
um doing the best to pass those lessons
on that's you know that was the goal
yeah
that should be everybody's school yeah
it's I when you you take that and you
transition into a civilian life
I tell people a couple things frequently
it is the minimum responsibility of
every American citizen to pass on to
their children in a country where they
have at a minimum the same ability to
choose
to have options
and we're failing at that as a society
collectively if you think about
what the government did to the
population during this covid crap
you can't deny there's five elements to
the First Amendment there's freedom of
religion freedom of speech freedom of
the press freedom of assembly and
freedom to seek regrets regret redress
for grievances right all of those were
smashed into the ground during covet
so it's our responsibility to make sure
that doesn't happen again how do we do
that we take the empiric knowledge from
what we went through these last two
years when we apply that nakedly
meaning we don't try to read into it we
just look at it and say what it is and
the government now is trying to hide
everything they're trying to do
everything back yeah which is one of the
worst things possible when you make a
mistake you know you go hey look I made
a mistake here right and this was this
was horrible during the whole thing
because hey if you think that this thing
spreads this way and it's good and you
look up three months later and that
turns out to not be true you say Hey
listen I made a mistake here we thought
it was this it was that here's the
adjustment you know I wouldn't send you
out on operation and say Hey you know I
want you to hit this target from the
north and you go okay okay boss sounds
good and you hit a couple IEDs on the
way in and you go hey Jocko there's IEDs
here I don't go well you just keep going
where I told you to go no I say hey look
I made a mistake on the analysis of the
scenario back out let's figure out a
better way no factor and by the way
you're you're not you don't lose respect
for me you go oh well Draco is willing
to admit that he made a mistake of the
analysis of this and learn from it and
learn from it and now we're gonna make
some adjustments and to see the egos
come out where there's no admission that
hey you know what I actually I I made a
bad assessment here it was wrong and
here's the adjustment we need to make
as far as I can tell right now and by
the way there's a decent chance of me
wrong again which which also is why I'm
not over committing and overstating
things right you know I always have fun
when I work with companies
and I'll say how often do you I know how
often do you people think I have to
admit that I'm wrong and people will
think oh you know because I talk about
being humble and they go oh you admit
that you're wrong all the time and I go
no I hardly ever have to admit that I'm
wrong and the reason I hardly ever have
to admit that I'm wrong is because I
hardly ever say I'm a hundred percent
right about this thing this is how we
should do this Mission or this is what
this means or this is how how to you
should interpret this no I say hey this
is what it looks like from my
perspective let's take a small step and
see what we learned that's it so I agree
with it mostly there but it's to me it's
not this is how I think we should do
this that's okay when when people
um and this is one of the things that we
had to break when we were writing all
that curriculum for uh Sr and land
Warfare this is how this is done
when you say to somebody this is how
this is done you're over
because this is how this was done at
this time in this place with this series
of variables yeah well so you actually
agree with what I said because what I
said is sort of well what I'm saying is
hey this is what I think we should do
right now not not this is what we should
do yes this is what I think we should do
right now no no no not this is this is
not what okay there's a difference so
this is what we should do it's different
than this is how this is done so this is
what we should do means that this is the
way that I think at this particular time
this should be done right because of
these variables it's open it's open this
is how this is done it's closed it's
wrong yeah decision making is not taken
place yeah so that's why I hardly ever
have to admit that I'm wrong because I
hardly ever say hey I'm 100 right about
this thing right here no you're not
going to catch me saying that because
how often can you be accurate with that
it's very very seldom that you're going
to be in a scenario where you know
something with 100 certainty it almost
never happens and I would rather even if
I'm 99 certain what do I gain out of you
know imposing some directive on you
right if you're working for me what am I
going to gain out of that you got your
perspective there's a decent chance you
see something I don't see so my mind's
open hey Derek I think Mike this might
be a good way to do this op and you go
well I don't agree okay well what do you
think let's talk
and my gut my my bias is to go with what
you say okay but that is my bias is to
you come up with a way to do something
doesn't matter if I'm it here's the
other interesting it doesn't matter if
we're peers or I'm your boss read or my
boss my bias is to go with what you say
now look if you're totally off the off
the res right and your idea is just
ridiculous well it's very easy for me to
articulate hey Derek I know you want to
do this you know jumping parachutes out
of the space shuttle but right it's
going to be really hard for us to get
the space shuttle for this operation in
a short period of time so I thought you
were Wheeling heat exactly
it's very easy to articulate that but it
if I'm having a hard time articulating
why I think something should be done a
certain way then that's a big indicator
that maybe it's not worth arguing and
maybe it's just easier to say okay you
know what Derek let's let's roll with
your dice if you're incapable of
articulating appropriately the
methodologies that you're applying to a
problem set you have not thought them
through well enough yeah boom yeah
Someone caught a seal how to read what's
up it's a real good indicator of that
uh
so you roll out on this deployment
you're doing some
would you say higher level what'd you
say what was your word for division one
up for division Warfare
um running around uh without a ton of
support if any and you get done with
that deployment uh we'll go into the
details of that one you come back what's
your next job okay I was gonna go teach
what I was doing
because I believe you should do that
right like we talked about that
um but then they came so I was a Senior
Chief at that point and the Billet the
job was for an E7 not an E8 and that's
when they went through and they said hey
look he used to be able to do one up one
down so the the bill it is for an E7 and
E6 could go do that or uh E8 right you
could do one up one down there right no
more of this we don't have enough guys
to do this stuff it's an E7 bullet
so I'm like oh man so I go check in it's
not the elephant cage at Advanced
Training and I was just kind of sitting
there and then like we got to find a E7
Billet you know and there was not
because that's a platoon chief job and I
just got done being a trip Chief nerd
you know so finally I go up to warcom
it's like a month into this and I feel
like I'm stealing money from the
government you know what I mean because
I'd go and checking her well we got
nothing to do and uh so I go up to
um pugs is the guy and um that's right
so I'm like pucks dude
I needed a job and he's like well I
don't know so he pulls up the list of
like all the seal billets on the planet
right and Bosnia I flew through Germany
Stuttgart biblingen
on the way there and on the way back
and I'm like and uh my wife she did like
a semester in Germany in college so I'm
like right there I want to go there he's
like okay so I get a Billet
I get a Billet as the j35 which is the
contingency operations ncyc at Special
Operations Command yard
that's why I went up there
yeah and uh you know I have an act for
the stuff I the upper division Warfare
stuff applies I understand how to you
know take very complex
problem sets and uh distill them down
into readily available and achievable
Solutions like it's just something I'm
good at and so I wrote all the
contingency up the soft response to
contingency operations plans for all the
countries in Europe
and then we developed further some of
them being executed right now I'm sure
yeah conventional Warfare campaign plan
for the Ukraine is one of them
um so at that time when I left in 2012
me and this other guy named Derek who's
a retired Special Forces colonel
we gave the ukrainians a month
like so we were planning for a Russian
invasion of the Ukraine in 2000 that's
2009 10. right people think the military
doesn't do so we do
um
but we gave them a month because the
authorities are different and what do
you mean you gave them a month we
thought within a month the Russians
would take over the entire country oh
got it like we gave a month DOD I think
was giving them about a week but you
know intuitively Derek had multiple
combat tours as special Force officers
the Fantastic officer
um
but we gave them a month because we knew
him better and um
then they changed the authorities when
this happened so you could give them
javelins and Stingers also the
the
weapons that are doing this so the the
Crux of the plan without getting you
know real deep into it is
disaggregated small unit operations
facilitated by high-tech weapons that's
it you know and then also you have
external intelligence and all that stuff
and that's what's taking place so that
truly was an amazing
uh
it was very intellectually stimulating
to do that and you know at that point
because I broke my back and all this
stuff and I can't carry a rock anymore
and uh that's really why I got out of
the teams is because I just couldn't do
the job physically I didn't want to
Brett Favre myself you know what I mean
which Brett should have just retired
dude Green Bay why'd you go to Minnesota
Brad I'm looking right into the camera
why did you do that
um so doing that really kept me engaged
in
um
in what was taking place really at that
point globally and um so Benghazi went
down when I was there and there were
still a sock half was getting stood up
Special Operations Command Africa and
there was a commanders in extremist
Force sharing agreement and you know so
it was I was really
um very deeply involved in the aftermath
of Benghazi
and everything that Clinton folks told
you and Obama is a lie in terms of what
that should not have happened
and as it was happening it should have
been stopped and and could have been
stopped right so I mean background on
that
um Jimmy Carter who previously was the
worst president in American history only
superseded by the current one Joe Biden
he is terrible he just is it's very
difficult to watch it's terrible I mean
it's painful
um so Jimmy Carter did something called
chief of mission Authority so the
American ambassador is real
title as chief of mission so the chief
of the Diplomatic Mission that's the
real title and Carter said look no
military forces will go into a country
without the approval of the chief of
mission unless it's a title 10
designated country meaning so title 10
is the Department of Defense thing and
we're like Hey we're going to invade
Iraq that becomes a title 10 deal the
military can move troops back and forth
into the country without going through
the state department
that was not the case for
uh Libya you know what I mean it wasn't
so in fact the state department has so
Ambassador Stevens had to approve the
troops that were on their way to
Benghazi had to approve them Landing in
the country but he was dead
and the state department didn't answer
the phone
Tina Kade now was there along with
secretary Clinton she's ultimately
responsible they just didn't answer the
phone
and birds were spinning up and there was
ready to roll
if if you look up Jackal Stone 12 I
think just Google it
Jackal stone is a special operations
forces
annual European exercise you probably
did it if you were two did you no okay
but I know but I know what the exercise
is okay so that was taking place in
Split Croatia and you know that the Sith
is there and they have a full pack none
of this is classified by the way
um they have a full package they've got
Shooters they got comms they got medical
they have resupply you know water
everything that bird was going there
because that's why it's there in case
something like that happens and the
agreement between sock F and and Sakura
was in place because soccer didn't have
a Sif yet yeah
right so but no one answered the phone
so you can't land that plane
and Ty woods man did you know Ty yeah
okay he's a total friend of mine
and I didn't know Glenn she was in my
class she was my bus class Tyler was yep
yep and he ended up getting rolled but
you know he spent uh you know right so
shameful and that I truly
I mean I knew it before because I'd seen
it on a macro level but I hadn't really
seen
on a excuse me on a micro level I've
seen it but on a macro level I hadn't
seen really the hardcore ramifications
of incredibly poor decision making other
than the fact we invaded Iraq when we
did I mean that was a big thing
um
but that really really brought it home
um that you just can't do that
you have to be if you're in a position
of leadership your phone is on all the
time yeah well actually Superior to that
is when you're in a position of
leadership you set up decentralized
command where people can make decisions
without having to run things all the way
up to the top yeah that's what you do
um that's the
um yeah I mean that's
that's how things should function great
now that depressing note yeah so so this
is what you're doing you get a really
um good look strategically at the world
through this tour that you do right that
sock your in a j35 Billet doing planning
and contingency planning and that's just
a a great view to go from being a troop
Commander literally on the ground and
then even as a troop Commander being for
this particular deployment
at a more even more tactical level than
a normal troop command but troop correct
but doing a strategic level Mission yes
and then but you're on the ground doing
it yeah that's the difference and then
you get to go to a a situation where
you're seeing the strategic planning for
these things that take place in the
future so there's a really good
education for you it's tremendous
and you do how many years over there 20
oh I did three years there and how many
kids you got at this point four they
speak German at this point nine
I couldn't graduated from my school
there though okay but it's in America
it's an American High School yeah yeah I
just one of my buddies ran into a team
guy and his kids are all speaking German
because he came back from there oh he
probably put him in the local schools
which you can do yeah we chose not to
check uh you get done with that what's
your next job after that Center for seal
and swick Excellence which is the school
house no that is the
um command that writes all the
advancement exams for seals it writes
the enlisted ladder people don't
understand when you join the Navy
um the Navy plans out a career for you
for 30 years
so even though you think you're joining
on a six-year enlistment or eight years
or whatever it is you know active and
reserved the Navy has a plan for you and
they Palm well I don't know what that
stands for but they budget for you being
in the military for 30 years and what um
at least the seal teams have done I
don't know if other communities do this
but you backwards plan on that so by the
time you're in E5 you've gone to this
school you've done this job e678 and it
goes all the way up that's the latter to
make sure that everybody is hopefully on
par with their institutional knowledge
um so I did that and it's really fun
right in the advancement exams because
I'd call all my buddies I'm like hey
will you go down to Florida with me for
a week we'll get locked in a skiff you
know a big safe and we'll go through the
previous exams and then we'll write new
questions updating the ttps and all of
the things for the SEAL Teams then in
order to get promoted seals would have
to take that yeah
um so that was awesome too that's a way
to get back to the community but I went
there because
um I needed to like get my medical
situation in order and it took like a
year and a half because at this point
you're just a beat up old frog man you
know what I mean that's why I'm fat
right now if I go PT right now I can't
walk I mean I've got a handicap placard
for my car damn yeah damn so I mean my
knees and hips and back and I got I got
a Ricochet in the face he was in
training does it counts for nothing I
didn't even get a free dental
appointment because of that you know
um so uh yeah I went there to you know
Dual Purpose get myself physically
you know up to par at least documented
appropriately so that when I retired
because I knew I was gonna retire
um you know it'd be less of a burden and
um so that's really what I did there and
again I've had
I've had the ability in the lock and I
think I'm blast man I mean I am I have a
deep and Abiding Faith in God and I I
look back you know all the way back to
getting hit in the head with the shackle
how that led to all this stuff
you know there's there's I I am one of
the luckiest human beings that has ever
existed
and I am so full of gratitude man I mean
I just I get up and I'm just full of
gratitude
and uh I I wish that more people
would understand the gifts that they've
been given
and understand they're a gift and when I
talk to folks
about the Cavalry thing like the
calories not coming over the hill I tell
them I go look man
um you're you're placed here at this
time you know with these people in this
circumstance by God
like you're put here for a reason and
from my perspective what I'm doing now
and the people I'm speaking to it's to
save the greatest country that has ever
existed in the history of the world
like the United States of America is an
exceptional nation and I don't tolerate
anybody talking crap about America it's
not going to happen and these folks that
I'm dealing with my you were placed here
by God
for that
to save the United States of America and
that's a gift
and you got to accept the gift and
oftentimes gifts you get this
oftentimes gifts
can be perceived as a burden
you know the gift of leadership that the
talk used to give the pressure you're in
that place at that time with those
people in that circumstance and these
things happen you're exercising the best
judgment that you're capable of doing
you have the best assets in the world
you're certainly working with the finest
human beings that have ever existed and
contextually in Warfare for sure and
then around the block you know
you were there for a reason
because you were given a gift to be able
to exercise that mission if you're
capable of doing something
and you don't act on it
you're not giving glory to God
you're given the intellectual or
physical ability to do things if you
don't do them
you're falling short
I believe that
other people need to understand that
what was it that made you decide that
you were going to retire you're at how
many years was this
that was I would say 24 I guess
when you made the decision yeah and I
retired at 26. how many kids did you
have that was before you were upset up
to your fourth yeah
um I just I knew that I couldn't do the
jobs level that that
it deserved did you have a retirement
plan what you're gonna do when you
retired no
no man we had bought a farm in Wisconsin
probably I don't know 10 years before
that and I wanted to just go back to my
farm who was taking care of the farm my
neighbors
how many acres is the farm uh it was 80.
and what kind of farm was it hey
and we raised animals and all that stuff
but so I got out and I did um this
corporate leadership stuff with Larry
for a couple years I mean I didn't stop
working and I did that and then it's
just what corporate leadership where you
were just helping corporations with
their leadership type thing and
Executive coaching sort of thing I mean
yeah the stuff you do but not nearly at
the same level I mean you've taken it
Beyond it okay you know uh and it wasn't
interesting to me so I'm like you know
what let's go back to the farm where
were you living when you were doing that
that was we lived in Maple Grove which
is Minnesota okay so you moved to
Minnesota after you retired for like a
year because we wanted our youngest son
to be able to graduate from high school
at that point he had gone to four
different high schools ouch so we found
a nice Christian Academy that's really
why I did all that stuff so that he
could have that period of time where he
could actually graduate from high school
in a place that and where we lived is
fantastic it was Butternut Wisconsin
it's a very small place and we just
wanted him to to be able to round out
his education in a Christian setting and
that was not available there
and then we went back to the farm and um
the the cafe in town
was called the butternut Cafe and
surprisingly enough but um it failed so
the owner of the building the person
running the cafe it didn't work well so
um it closed there's
326 people in the village
and um
these people had they had taken care of
our farm for like a decade I went to
Afghanistan Iraq the Horn of Africa and
was stationed in Germany for three years
nothing happened to that place
not a window broken of my neighbors Tom
and Maria shulkey Dave Muller front lawn
is like an acre and they would not take
money for gas we are not your servants
we're your neighbors I mean that's what
these that people think that Americans
are like these they the image of
Americans
it's not Manhattan dude that's it I mean
I live in America and people bend over
backwards we have so much more in common
with each other than differences and
it's being exploited by these folks that
are trying to do I think horrible things
for the country but that's really
American where I live now in Prairie Du
Shane it's America you know so this
place closes the village takes a huge
hit and I'm like bam
so I talked to Sergey and I'm like let's
get this going again sorry I bought the
building from the bank
gutted it put in new equipment I I
worked in a restaurant for I don't know
like a year or something before I joined
the Navy Sarah was a waitress for you
know three months in high school
but you know I'm a quick study I love
cooking I've cooked around the world you
know I did I've made Bread on five
continents dude like Made bread from
flour I haven't made Bread on one you
should try this dude it's cathartic
um so we got the cafe going again and
then sold it to a local lady my BFF her
name is Bobby Munoz she's awesome and um
you know not surrounding so
so many people talk about things
and a lot of people have money and
they'll throw money at problems you know
the government tries to throw money at
problems right
if you say you're going to do something
do it in the most valuable gift you can
give somebody is
your time
you have a finite amount of time on this
planet now I as a Christian I believe
that you know something Beyond this but
a lot of people that don't
you only have you only have so much time
so if you really care about somebody
give them your time sit down with them
give them time so we we gave two years
of our time
back to that Village because they're so
dear to us
and you know I walked away net neutral
but the impact of showing people
demonstrating to them that you truly
care about them
Priceless
you know what I mean no absolutely
um you
build this business back up
you sell the whole thing to your BFF
your BFF what's your BFF's name Bobby
Bobby but Bobby's a female female okay
she's awesome so Bobby's now running the
business uh she has she had uh Jenny
run that and Bobby started Bobbers on
the lake and butternut Lake and if you
want to go by and get a beer okay well
this is important to put out because
people are going to want to hit these
places yeah so Bobbers bobber's on the
lake uh it's in Butternut Wisconsin run
by Bobby Munoz I actually want to go to
both these places and I don't even drink
beer so right Bobby is
a whirling dervish
I mean she is on the Go I mean you have
all these different you know
entrepreneurial Adventures she's got the
same thing going I mean she says
okay so you you sell that business and
now you move back to the farm no so I'm
living on the farm okay you're living on
the farm and then I'm turning 50. so
this was
three years ago now
and I'm like this this is another point
in my life where you can either
you know kind of like just stay stagnant
or
you should do something to keep yourself
rolling right so I'm like I'm gonna go
to law school
and just like buds man you can't just go
to law school like why can't I just go
to law school right so I studied for the
LSAT for a month on the Khan Academy
which is awesome it's free you know and
Chuck and I got accepted to law school
uh Mitchell Hamline in St Paul but
during so during this period of time
we did what we call cousin Camp so we
got all the cousins so you know our my
brother-in-law's and all the kids to 570
people
we get them all together and um they
were given Sarah
excuse me
hard time about how difficult it was
because at this point we had four
grandkids I think and we're having
yeah we had we were having we had three
we're having our fourth fifth and six
grandkids they're gonna be born in a
two-month window
and um
so they're giving Sarah Jane a hard time
about how difficult it was to visit our
farm way up North
and it was like an hour and 45 minutes
to the closest Regional Airport and then
if you're flying there it's the next 200
bucks a person you know I'm not a
wealthy guy we live on our list of
retirement I can't afford that stuff and
uh or you find in Minneapolis and it's
like a four and a half hour drive so I'm
like Chuck got it I miss the kids
growing up I did you know I was working
deployed training all that stuff
so I set preconditions
two of them well I love that place up
there it took us 15 years to get the
house you know up to it was just perfect
and um
like two conditions
um right the family wants you to move my
wife wants us to go someplace closer to
an airport so that our grandkids can
visit us and we can visit them already
right and I missed our kids growing up
yeah because I was you know Frogman
natural environment combat and um
so I was two conditions it has to be in
Wisconsin
and it has to be a hobby Farm
so I get on the old internet in the
kitchen and the farm I find this place
in Hager City
which oh I did a a one hour
circumference around the Apple same park
got it right and it had to be on what I
call the right side of the river that's
politically in you know geographically
correct
um and so uh I find this place in Hager
City
I call them it's going on the market the
next day small hobby Farm old farmhouse
19 Acres 13 killable Alfalfa not hay
anymore
check
I drive down the next day I look at it I
go okay this is it put in an offer by
the house move down there
did you sell the other place uh we sold
it after a couple months right yeah so
it's gone and um excuse me
so interestingly enough
this is how I wound up Brenny for
Congress
because
Sean Duffy who was my rep for the
longest time if you look at Wisconsin
the Ashland County is like right in the
middle
to the top right and it's right next to
Lake Superior just past Glidden which is
the next Village up from Butternut it
becomes very liberal because there's a
environmentalist liberal arts college
here North Northlands college right
so Sean and his crew would stop in
butternut and he's a U.S congressman
he's now he's on Fox all the time with
Rachel campus stuff here great couple
nine kids but so they would stop in our
village and I'd cook for him and his
staff
so if something was coming up he'd be
like oh I'll just call Sean and ask him
what's going on you know and um so I
moved down and it that's in Pierce
County
right which is in the third
congressional district not the seventh
congressional district I don't know any
of this stuff I've never tracked
politics or anything right so I'm like
oh this impeachment was coming on I did
human intelligence for a very long
period of time
I read the Steele dossier and I knew it
was absolute junk
this is manufactured this is not true it
was submitted by a guy who was a former
British intelligence officer that was
clearly colluding with Russian
Intelligence Officers to produce this
thing and it's paid for by who no I knew
it was junk right so I'm like who's my
congressman you know because it's not
Sean anymore guy named Ron kind I'm like
whoa Hey Ron kind what's your stance on
the impeachment of Donald Trump
for the Russian collusion stuff didn't
write me back
nothing crickets chirping and I'm like
what dude the job title is
representative it's not your lordship
you know I mean this is not how
representative democracy is supposed to
function and it sure didn't with Sean
so I'm getting steamed and I start
looking into this cat right I mean
finding terrorists in Pakistan is super
hard you know what I mean it's very
difficult it is not difficult finding
out what politicians are doing
so I started looking at this guy from
the perspective of doing human
intelligence and finding out what this
cat had been doing he'd been in office
for 22 or 23 years at the time saying
stuff in the district you can find it in
newspaper articles and and uh interviews
and then I'd compare that to his actual
voting record and it was just wrong
he would say one thing go to DC and do
another thing because he was working for
the behest of special interest groups
not the people he's representing right
so the impeachment vote goes down
he is number 435 out of 435
representatives to cast his vote made
public on the floor because he had to
told everybody in the district he wasn't
going to vote for that impeachment
because it was junk
I'm not doing that well he did it hoping
to slide it under the radar nope so I
sent a text message to this guy named
Jim who worked for Sean I'm like Jim
who are you guys running against this
guy he writes me back and he goes to you
and I write him back and he didn't write
me back so when you write something and
somebody writes hahaha and they don't
write back they're not joking
and I was like
oh yeah
well I should be I fixed problems for
decades
so why aren't I fixing this problem and
I decided to run for Congress
so I got a hold of the rpw
Mark Jefferson is executive director did
an interview with him and he's like wow
yeah I guess you know and I formed this
nascent
political group you know is this 2019
this should be 2019 yeah so in 2019 and
um
I for my my team I didn't know what I
was doing here's here's the metrics
people like hearing these metrics so Ron
kind had been in office for at that
point 24 years 25 years something like
that
he had 3.1 million dollars in the bank
he had a functioning political
organization
and he had 100 name recognition
100 kind right they have those kind bars
that's not him
um I had never thought about being in
politics ever my entire life right we
moved to the district to be closer to
the airport so we can visit our children
so the only person that knew my name was
my wife right I have no money at all
zero name recognition that's that's the
starting point I decide to run for
office 72 hours I announced my candidacy
they locked down the entire planet with
covet
boom
so I ran a nine-month campaign
against those odds I came within like
two and a half points of beating this
guy and he wound up spending over six
million dollars against me
that's why he resigned
this is I announced my candidacy I lost
and I tried to this is this is amazing
you know you can say whatever you want
about the 2020 election but I did the
math I look at this I lost by eleven
thousand votes I got I can't make up
eleven thousand votes you know what I
mean even if we found statistical
anomalies and all that stuff that's what
I mean I can't you know I'm not going to
be able to overcome that I try to call
that cat I go that night like four in
the morning
calling to concede the election right
because you should right he wouldn't
take the phone call
interesting not interesting that's
egotistical person who's whose entire
being is based on being a politician who
liked being called Congressman have
people open their doors for him
and I got so close to beating him like
all throughout the night I was ahead and
then like 15 000 votes show up at you
know 2 30 in the morning or whatever you
know I get a check they're counting
ballots that come in I get it
um he was so angry
he wouldn't take a phone call that's
someone who has no business being in
leadership anywhere
right I've heard it start losers start
winners what
so um
yeah I decided to to run again because I
was talking to Sarah Jane I mean really
that night I go
this is not going to bode well for the
country not me personally I mean my ego
it's over here this is not about me
um it's not it's about our country and
our grandkids at that point we had six
grandkids you know we've eight now so
I understood that I had no idea it was
going to get this bad this fast no one
could predict this you just can't you
could not but I decided to run again I
waited I shepherded everything I did
some changes in my team
and then we wound up running the number
one political campaign in the entire
nation for 2021 from Prairie du Chien
you know 5600 people
and then what what makes you classify
something that's the number one
political campaign in the whole country
so what the inside baseball stuff
because everybody understands
intuitively or they just know it
um is that in order to get a word out
you have to be able to raise enough
funds to to get the word out you know I
don't get any money for my campaign you
can take a salary from a campaign I
don't I just don't think that's you
should do that but you have to buy
television advertising cable you can
print media you got to pay a staff you
know all this stuff gasoline and
whatever so um
yeah we raise more money than any
Republican Challenger in the entire
nation in 2021. well what drove that me
and my team
I have an exceptionally good team I'm so
incredibly proud of my team and you
you can perform at a high level for only
a certain period of time you know this
you got to sleep at some time so how do
you how do you pull off sustained
Superior performance you make sure that
you assemble the best thing you possibly
can so I have incredibly dedicated
people who are all on board for the
right reasons I interviewed every single
one of them personally and make sure
that they're in this for something
Beyond themselves which is the country
that's why we're successful our mission
is completely pure the message is pure
and we're here for the right reasons we
want to save our country and that's very
very rare I think there are some
fantastic people in public office and
Leadership right now they are they're
fantastic a lot of them but other people
are just kind of there they're the
dude that was the marops instructor for
15 years you know at trade it they're
doing a function
but you know why are they doing it
that's why we're successful so what does
this look like from here on out from
what what what's the next however how
many months are we away right now we're
not we're 42 days 42 days away and what
does the next 42 days look like
I work
um
I am meeting meeting meeting meeting
meeting meeting this is my schedule I've
been doing this for three years dude
who do you meet with I meet with a bunch
of different people
um my favorite meetings are with the
guys in the district the people I'm
going to be representing what is going
on man
like how is your farm doing
what is affecting you so that you can or
cannot provide for your family as well
biggest thing we get input costs through
the roof Joe Biden
cancel the Keystone Pipeline okay check
this out a guy named Tim Michaels is
running for governor and he's been a
friend of mine for I don't know three
years now or something
start he had his dad started a company
had a couple of hundred employees he has
like 8 000 now
he's gonna win
he calls me
like the day or so after Biden gets
sworn and goes Derek I just had to lay
off 700 people
and I'm like what do you mean Ken he's
like uh we were doing the electrical
substations for the Keystone Pipeline
and Biden just went frick
shut that off
so the cascading effects of these things
people don't understand and I do
intuitively because I wrote all these
plans and did this stuff and it's
something I'm good at so here's what
happens when you stop natural gas
movement and production do you know
where fertilizer comes from Jocko yeah
natural gas that's the nitrogen that
comes for that's where it comes from the
Wisconsin's Third District is one of the
top five users of propane and natural
gas for Home Heating in the country it
gets 20 degrees below zero okay you're
not going to like put an extra sweater
on like your mom used to tell you what
about solar
wait okay so check it out
um we we want our grandchildren to have
power right but we have kids now so the
Biden administration's trying to skip
ahead a generation you can't do that um
the guy named Brent Ridge runs um
Dairyland power one of the biggest
co-ops in my district and we have a lot
of co-ops because they're rural
um they did the math
so the Biden Administration wants to be
carbon neutral by 2030.
okay well a noble goal you know what
that takes you have to double the amount
of all of the nuke plants on the entire
planet
so that is not a real goal
it's just not so people are eating it
right now because of these horrible
policies
just that simple and it's got to stop
man yeah you know uh one people that are
in business with me and there's a lot of
them you know we got a lot of a lot of
different businesses sure and and anyone
that works with me knows that when I'm
looking at things and we're you know
assessing something I'll get to a point
where I say all right run the numbers
right you know which is okay well tell
me what this is going to cost how much
we're going to put into it what's the
ROI look like what's the risk run the
numbers tell me what the numbers look
like because that's ultimately and and
then the numbers you have to put that
into the calculus of your gut feeling
for sure
but you can have a really strong
positive gut feeling like hey this
sounds like a great idea and then you
run the numbers you go hey it's probably
not going to work man like that's just
too much sometimes you go you know what
this is not a bad idea you run the
numbers and you go hey this actually
makes sense we can we can go for this
and and that's why I kind of you know
when you mention the closing of the
pipeline I kind of you know because
emotionally you think well this seems
like a positive thing you know people
can look at it go hey well we don't want
to have to put
um pipes through fields and
and then you run the numbers right yeah
and you just run the numbers and it's
not even really that close you know it's
the type of math that you just said oh
we got to double the number of nuclear
plants in the next three years if we're
gonna get there that's what it's going
to take in the world in the world right
uh so check this out man we don't do
enough running of numbers right so
you know when you go to your house let's
say You're Gonna wash your hands
and you turn the faucet on and a little
train car comes with water right and
then you then you pour the water out of
the train car no how does it get into
your faucet with a pipe yeah because
it's the most efficient way to transport
fluids it's not even close right and
it's so and then you want to like light
your gas stove does the little train
come and then you get gas no that comes
from a pipe too now trains themselves we
I'm in Prairie Du Shane it's like train
City USA man
transporting bulk items like coal for
instance and some other large Pol things
if you're going from point to point you
have to have a rail head right so
there's room for both of them that's
what folks don't understand but we have
a carbon-based economy
and if you shut off the the fossil fuels
that produce carbon
you're going to destroy the economy
that's what's happening right now you
look at the food costs dude Farmers have
not locked away check it out firmish
have not locked in fertilizer prices for
next year so it's going to keep going up
and up and up there is a um there's two
fertilizer plants that just close in
England there's one in Finland that went
down I think they're only going to
produce 24 of the fertilizer that they
did before Russia is not going to export
fertilizer anymore probably for the
future at least five years I mean they
hate us right now and there's these
weird tariffs that we put on Morocco
where they they produce some fertilizers
what can Congress do one thing
right now uh put pressure on the body
Administration to make sure that they
open up permitting and then get rid of
the tariffs on Morocco
so looking at all of these problems
people get really worried about a lot of
stuff
and uh the current leadership the
Republican party uh Kevin McCarthy in
the house we actually have a plan
and they've done a tremendous job of
looking at all the problems and figuring
out which one of these from the federal
level will we have the greatest
probability of having the greatest
positive effect
you know that's how you're supposed to
govern so I'm I'm actually very excited
um the polls are looking outstanding for
us when I say us I mean my team
um I know I'm the head of the team but
us we've done this together
so I anticipate you know being elected
in November and giving it a go man it's
not funny I think about that dude I come
from the meanest circumstances
well you know uh when I kind of open
with that thing for George Washington
that I'd heard that quote read that
quote a while ago and you know you think
about
you know I I just know your career and
know what you know as an average team
guy what you've done what you've been
put through what your family's been put
through and it's like how much you're
gonna ask from somebody and I look at
the political Arena and it makes me sick
to my stomach like I I don't I just
think that just sounds the whole thing
sounds awful when you show me your
calendar and I know you're going to a
bunch of meetings with people that half
of them you know are horrible people
half of them are awesome people you got
all this craziness going on
um I would not say that okay vast
majority of them are awesome okay like
Fast well I know that when I look at
what happens to politicians uh and
you're gonna get just you know your your
life becomes this uh Target right and so
I know that there's a ton of sacrifice
that you and your family are going to
make again in order to do this and uh
yeah I guess you wouldn't be setting
meetings with people that despise you
but look the Press is going going to
absolutely a large majority of the press
will absolutely despise you and they're
going to do everything to attack you
they're going to attack your family
they're going to attack your values your
home your people your community and
everything
um so the the fact that you're like yeah
cool Roger that gonna step up and and
try and make this happen and looks like
you are going to make this thing happen
yeah
when you look at
um all the divisiveness in the country
right now
one of the things that I've given an
answer to a bunch is something that we
already kind of discussed which is hey I
look at something from my perspective
and I think well you know Derek has a
good point there or maybe he's right
about this instead of me thinking well
Derek doesn't agree with every single
point that I have so therefore he's
completely wrong about everything and I
actually hate him
how are we trying to open people's minds
up to get hey you know what I I get that
you see things a little bit differently
and you come from a different background
than me and I I understand your idea
at least I know where you're trying to
go and it seems like in most cases we
can be at least somewhat aligned you
know you want
for food prices to come down right that
seems like a universal Universal thing
who would say no we think food should be
more expensive so what we really should
be talking about is if you want food
prices to come down
and let's say you're a conservative
you're a Conservative Republican and
let's say I'm a a left-wing Democrat
right and I want food prices to come
down so we're actually aligned on where
we want to go on that particular subject
right
but
it's like there can't even be agreement
on that
and we can't have a logical discussion
about well okay we'll run the numbers
show me the numbers that you're looking
at and I'll show you the numbers that
we're looking at and let's have a
discussion about how we can actually
make the food prices come down let's try
and figure something out
how do we cross that bridge
well how I plan on Crossing that bridge
so first and foremost everyone needs to
understand that I will work with anybody
who's willing to put the interest of the
country above their own
I don't care who you are I will work
with you and I've proven that over 26
years working the most diverse
environments and hostile straight up
hostile environments people trying to
kill me environment so if you're going
to put the betterment of the country in
your congressional district above your
own personal interest I'm on board
um
and this is this is what I tell people
to Echoes what you're you're saying I
said um
you're going to agree with people
oftentimes 90 of the time
you know if I agree with somebody 90 of
time that's that's a big win right
how many people here can look themselves
in the mirror and honestly say that you
agree with your spouse 90 of the time
almost nobody right so finding common
ground that's the term finding common
ground is imperative to make sure that
you can actually govern
and when you do things strictly on party
lines you lose the ability to closely
identify common ground how Congress has
gotten around this
is they put these big Omnibus bills
together so you're going to using your
example this is going to
unleash America unleash American energy
therefore the input cost for farming are
going to go down that means food costs
are going to go down or this is going to
decrease the price of diesel fuel which
decreases the transportation you
understand right and then they'll put
something in here
like
um but we're gonna have red flag laws
and you're gonna have your guns
confiscated confiscated by the state you
know which I fundamentally did that is
just wrong right and they put them in
the same bill
so that they can vote on it
for or against it and they can justify
it when they go back to their District
that's got to stop
it has to stop because in no way shape
or form do I support red flag loss I'll
give you an example a well-regulated
militia being necessary for the security
of a free state the right for the people
to keep in their arms shall not be in
French that's the entire text of the
Second Amendment dude so that's out but
lowering food cost is in so in order to
hold Congress accountable Congress has
to write clean legislation
so that I know exactly where Jocko and
Echo sit on an issue that's got to
happen are we going to be able to pull
it off I don't know
um
but one of the things that I will do
that everybody can count on is I will do
me
meaning like the first pledge that I
make to everybody is I will not buy sell
or trade individual stocks as long as
I'm a sitting member of Congress I will
not do that
and people are like well what about this
guy what about that guy what about that
y'all I'm gonna do me
I'm going to make sure that all the
things I'm doing are as morally and
ethically and legally correct as I
possibly can as a human being when I'm
in Congress I'll start there
encourage is contagious we talked about
that
I mean ideally
people will see that
and the people that I'm working with
they'll want to do that too
I mean people inherently
you know they want to do things in a way
that's beneficial for other people the
American people are benevolent we're the
most generous country that has ever
existed are populist you know the
Regular People
on the street
so if you give them the opportunity to
do what's right A lot of people are
going to do what's right they just need
to see somebody else do it
you know what I mean yeah and I think
um
America right now you know you know
you're looking at anybody looks at some
Bill that's coming before Congress
coming before the house and it's
whatever
792 Pages you don't even read it and and
there's not one person America that goes
that seems like a good thing
and you could go down a whole laundry
list of things that every American says
this is [__] what this is [__]
what you just talked about like having
these multiple different
um yeah Omnibus bills where you got all
these different categories that are
being voted on in one bill every
American every American goes that's
[__]
and there's only so long that the
politicians can continue to get away
with this [__] before Americans
because you gotta remember we're the
people that were like oh you're going to
raise the the tax on T by two two cents
per uh per freaking giant bundle of tea
yeah no actually we're gonna we're gonna
fight you at some point Americans go hey
this is [__] and we're gonna get rid
of you people that are doing these
things that are clearly wrong they're so
clearly wrong everybody knows it and
eventually you say oh yeah we're done
now look I I don't even think it's good
I think it's going to be a change like
you're like you're the personification
of this change right that's not like
that everyone's gonna get voted out
tomorrow but people go oh yeah here's a
guy that just went in there and said
yeah this is a dumb idea hey you guys
can't pull a wool over the Americans
eyes anymore I think over the next
several years maybe even take five maybe
even take 10 years we're gonna get rid
of these things that are for lack of a
better word [__] right so I I want
to be very clear uh
I am absolutely I 100
disavow any type of political violence
I do not condone it and that will be the
destruction of America if we take up
arms against each other I'll have no
part of that first time I want to combat
Bosnia Herzegovina Civil War went to
Afghanistan turned into a civil war Iraq
turned into Civil War worked in the Horn
of Africa Civil War I'll have no part of
that in the United States of America so
how do we prevent that from happening
which I will do anything to prevent that
from happening
political violence cannot be part of a
discussion in the United States of
America it cannot so how do we do it we
do it by what you're saying we exercise
our rights as American citizens and we
get into office and we make the change
from the inside and here's here's what's
this is fascinating dude
okay
ask not what your country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country you
wanna say that
John F Kennedy JFK said that right so he
said that in 62.
61-62. so we went from that ask not what
your country can do for you ask what you
can do for your country we went from
that to
you're going to do everything I say
you're going to do you're going to lock
your church you're going to close your
business you're not going to be able to
speak to each other freely you're going
to go to this store but not that store
you're going to get a shot or you're
going to get fired you're going to do
everything you're going to give me your
money the sweat of your brow and if you
don't willingly do this I'm going to use
the full course of power of the federal
government to compel you to do this you
got that who's that
that's AOC
so the Democrat Party went from JFK to
AOC
in 50 some years how
Republicans let them
something goes wrong in a mission who's
the first person you look at dude it's
you what did I do or not do that led to
the failure of this mission
hopefully you're saying what did I do or
not do that led to the success of this
mission right never take anything for
granted so we as Republicans have let
people get away with this for such an
extended period of time and we've done
it by saying oh you know they have the
best interest of the country at hand
they really do they want the same things
that we do yeah some aspects you do but
in other others they don't I mean
there's people that want to
fundamentally change the system of
government that is has proven to be the
best one in the entire planet like ever
in history you know what I mean we we're
one of the youngest countries in the
world we have the oldest standing
constitution in the world
why because it is an incredibly
functional and beautiful document
there's people that want to throw the
Constitution out why because they're not
getting away the they're not getting
their way
so the the beauty about our constitution
is something's wrong in it
the mechanism for changing it is written
into the document itself it's the
amendment process you know what I mean
so use it and they're like well it's so
hard yeah it's very it's supposed to be
right so are we changing stuff yeah are
people waking up to how destructive this
uh the policies have
the destructive effect that the policies
are having yeah I mean I see people that
are just beside themselves that ten
thousand dollar College thing
they want to give ten thousand dollars
to for you know student debt relief
check this out man 75 percent of my
district does not have a four-year
degree only nine percent of my district
nine percent has a graduate degree
and I did a round table with some folks
and they're all blue collar folks this
is what 21 000 square feet yeah okay
um this gym is 21 000 square feet is
what he's referring yeah sorry the gym
is 28 000 square feet or do this thing
at a HVAC place it's probably 18 20 000
square feet two brothers got this thing
going they don't have ice they have high
school degrees and then trade school
we're in this you know beautiful
business all the people are just real
estate agents whatever no one had a
four-year degree and we're like well
what do you think about this like well
this is absurd right so I do this round
table I go to a place to get lunch I'm
talking to Hannah is her name H in the
beginning H at the end I remember
because she said that stuck my mind and
we started talking she goes yo this is
great you know I graduate from college I
have all this debt you know I'm working
here as a bartender and her degree was
our degree was in um
she was like public or Communications
with the art major or art minor right
I'm like well you know
kind of get what you pay for there she
goes yeah I think it's ready to go okay
here hold on a sec let's say this place
is banging on a Friday night and there's
there's a hundred people here and you go
all right time out 91 of you go over
there
okay and the 91 the other nine you sit
here
all 91 of you are going to pay for
everything they eat and drink tonight
and you're gonna sit there and watch
them
and go would they be mad she goes well
yeah that's just unfair and I was like
okay so 91 folks
even if they're just getting it you know
you're talking
25 bucks a person maybe I mean they
could have lavish dinner right
so this is twenty five hundred dollars
out of every single American taxpayers
wallet to pay for somebody to have
dinner on you no that doesn't make sense
on any planet right and I told her then
she's like wow yeah that is just unfair
I'm like Hannah
and I run the numbers walk the dog
that's what I call it walk the dog on
this you know what I mean it doesn't
make sense so people are seeing that and
um I
there's so many reasons to be
discouraged Jocko and you can always
find one you can always find no
your nose easy
it is it's the easiest thing in the
world no
um and it's easy to get discouraged it's
easy to get down you know with all the
circumstances but I'm telling you if you
wake up in the morning like I do and you
just have
overwhelming sense of gratitude like we
talked about just just so gracious look
at yourself look at look at the things
that opportunities that you have as a
human being the United States of America
right now to create something
to do something worthwhile to help
somebody out that doesn't exist in a lot
of countries and when you just take a
minute and go like yeah you know I'm
gonna go buy that cop a cup of coffee I
do that for cops and they're like oh I'm
sorry sir I can't accept a gift I'm like
you're not the boss me dude like I don't
work for you police officer X you know
I'm buying you this cup of coffee dude
or you help out a homeless person like
help them out not just throw money at
them because that doesn't help anybody I
mean it doesn't the ability to do that
is unique
and we got to remember that and you got
to tell your friends
and you got to encourage your friends to
tell other people
because you've seen the downward spiral
you know when things start going bad and
then it's just that it's this this
negative feedback loop that people get
into we're in a negative feedback loop
but the inputs are coming from our
government
and we should be in a negative feedback
loop feedback loop right now so how do
you get out of that you put goodness in
there
that's what we're doing
it's I mean some things are
so basically you know philosophical it
was interesting teaching special
reconnaissance because you have time to
reflect when do you have time to reflect
and I mean they started with videos
remember they're like two minutes long
then they made them one minute then they
made them 30 seconds oh you're just
talking about social media videos yeah
they're what seven seconds now yeah so
there's been a crunch of the attention
span of people and it it removes your
ability to reflect on something you
truly don't understand something until
you ponder it
and teaching special reconnaissance and
doing Special reconnaissance missions
you have time to ponder things yes you
do and sometimes pondering while you're
freezing and starving you know but um
and again starting as a kid you know
reading so much
reading takes time and reflection and
when you're you're putting an author's
voice
inside of your mind because you're
reading it and you're you know you're
hearing that inside you're not receiving
this like a television image
it's you internalize it wow
so we're putting some good in there yeah
we're injecting good into the cycle
seriously so be encouraged I want you
listen people I want you to be
encouraged you live in the best country
in the world if you're in America right
now and if you're not move here legally
emigrate to the United States of America
and we'll welcome you with open arms if
you do it the right way
Jack
that gets us I think that gets us up to
date that's where we're at right
um these are excellent by the way oh
thank you yeah thank you appreciate it
yeah I haven't had one before I guess
you have this whole line of everything
right we got a lot of a bunch of stuff
you know we got a we got a
we're making supplements here okay we've
got clothing we got factories we got two
factories in Maine we got
maybe three factories in Maine depending
on what you're counting as a factory and
we just Consolidated or we're in the
process of consolidating our two
factories in North Carolina to one
Factory in North Carolina back up why
don't you have a factory in the third
congressional district of the state of
Wisconsin we can talk about that let's
talk about that
um we can go out there and check it out
and as as we grow which we're growing
very rapidly right now and the reason
we're growing very rapidly is because
people want American-made stuff sure hey
dude we've got power we've got rail
during the summer time we've got the
Mississippi River to move Commodities up
and down and I have the most Fantastical
hard-working ethically sound badass
Americans in the world well the the that
is that is outstanding and and
that's what we're looking for
um you know we've we've kind of we're a
little bit maxed out our resources our
human capital up in Maine we're still
getting people that are I mean it's the
beautiful things we've got people coming
in from all over the country are moving
to Maine moving to North Carolina
knocking on the door I want a job I want
to work here it's it's outstanding uh
and so that's been a huge part of it
um just growing that but yeah we make
boots we make jeans we make hunt gear so
American-made hunt gear I don't think
there's anyone more patriotic in the
world than
hunters in the in the country than
Hunters Hunters need to vote like 30 100
vote oh really that little we all sit
around and are you know griping about
this and that they don't vote
if you're a hunter vote yeah register
and vote no doubt about it there's no
doubt about it though if you're not part
of the problem for hunting rights for
gun rights for conservation like you you
definitely want to be voting if you're
not voting right now but they definitely
I mean I saw a bunch of hunters over the
past you know September the past hunting
season for me and everyone is just so
excited about being able to buy stuff
that's made in America because this is
you're literally taking money out of our
economy when you buy something from
overseas you're just giving that money
not only giving it overseas but they
don't care about the environment at all
right in these overseas factories they
definitely don't take care of their
workers their workers have no future
they're slave labor it's it's it's it's
horrible we're paying the Chinese
Communist party to oppress their people
and plot against the existence of the
United States that's what is happening
and that's what me and my friends are
doing to push back against that is bring
bringing manufacturing back to America
you love it we we are literally we have
have literally
brought machines that were outsourced to
America from America 30 years ago we've
bought them and have brought them back
to America and are putting them to use
that's what we're actually doing it uh
right now I mean we got we got a great
documentation of this too uh so that's
what we're doing well I'll tell you what
dude
um
let me get elected keep working hard and
then uh student official visit yeah
because I listen
um I will do anything to help the people
that I'm representing those three
conditions morally ethically and legally
correct then we got we have to find ways
that meet those parameters with the end
state of your congressional district the
state and the country are better off
because of it yeah and it's it's just a
little nose to the grindstone dude you
really got to think about what's taking
place and then act on it yeah well a
huge part a huge part of what you're
talking about is you know you've said it
multiple times you got to put your
country first and you know when when
I've as I've gotten involved in the in
these industries you you can look back
very easily in the last 40 years 30
years really of the history of the
companies in America where you can
increase your profits your short-term
profits
by a little percentage and therefore you
make this and oh you know what we can we
can it's going to cost us more to get it
over here it's going to cost us to
transport it it's going to cost us time
but we got plenty of time because we're
big and it's going to save us you know
38 cents a garment right let's do it and
that's what they did right and they did
that over and over again and then they
spread the LIE of not not what they what
we were up against is they said oh you
can't it's impossible to do this in
America now right it's important I was
like are you kidding me this is America
it's America if this is America we out
produce the world right and we can build
anything we can make anything and that's
what we're doing and look it starts with
boots and clothing and jeans and Jiu
Jitsu Gis and rash guards that's where
we're starting I don't know where we're
going to finish but that's what we're
doing so we we have a we have a globally
integrated economy
right it's carbon based and and I'm okay
with that too to an extent where I'm not
is I'm not a globalist
and I understand that
we need to make sure that we're putting
the interest of our people
first and the best example of this is
let's say you're
um you know 98 year old person with
osteoporosis or whatever and you see
someone being assaulted
can you help that person
no I mean he called police but you can't
get in there so you you have to be
strong in order to help somebody
and this Administration
either doesn't understand that or they
don't care
so when you are the difference between
equality and Equity is
everyone should have
the
everyone should have the ability to
start with a Level Playing Field you
know what I mean and then you you
succeed or fail
predicated on your god-given gifts and
your drive right but if I force you
to perform less so that you have equity
Vice equality it ruins everything
is brilliant yeah we've been kind of
exploring bringing them out to uh bring
them on the podcast because you do we've
can I talked about him a bunch and uh
and he's definitely had a big influence
on the way that I think quality of
opportunity not outcome yeah just a
brilliant man
[Music]
um
yeah so Echo yeah what's up man do you
have any questions yeah let's rewind a
little bit oh oh boy you're working at a
gas station yes did you have any
roommates at that time no I was working
at dry style Chevron so you could work
at Chevron and have your own apartment
granted we're starving for sure wait so
check this out
um you guys are you do you track um
Dennis Prager yeah okay so Prager you
they did you know the series of four
minute videos they they did this one
there's if you do three things it
doesn't matter where you start
on the lower socioeconomic scale you're
going to wind up in the middle class
you graduate from high school
you do not have a child out of wedlock
and you have a full-time job
that could be at the gas station that
could be anywhere right so you do these
three things statistically you're going
to wind up in the middle class
it just takes those things and a lot of
people give Guff about um
intergenerational wealth transfer right
well
we were raised dirt poor but my ma
because she was a hard worker when she
died she had a home
and we sold the home because we didn't
want to live there and then we had to
pay a bunch of taxes and then we
received this you know a little nestec
from my mom
that's money that went from one
generation to another
that is intergenerational
wealth transfer and all it takes I mean
that's what it is I mean look you don't
get to make up the worst seals seals
make up definitions of words all the
time by the way okay yeah they'll change
your name you know uh Jason I'll say his
name Jason uh Jason Cabell yeah okay so
Jay Bell's this nickname he was in Buds
and they're like were you in buds with
him no I was not he's after me okay so
Jay Bell is anything you know chasing
about he was my who is my lpo when I was
at Team seven okay he just uh finished
directing an episode of Seal Team oh
right over in Jordan I think yeah so
we're buddies I did him uh he asked me
he's like hey I want you to play an
airships captain in a movie I'm
directing with Nicolas Cage and I'm like
okay I was working at the cafe I've
never chased acting before but he called
me because they're friends we're like
all right sure I'll do that but um so J
Bell he's in Buds and they're like get
over here like get over here cable and
he's like it's Cabell and he's like
don't Church it up
your name is cable so it's literally
changing her yeah so sorry yeah gas
station poor yeah but you had your own
apartment though sure I'm just saying it
seems like here in here in San Diego
anyway if I work at Chevron I don't
think I'm getting my own apartment then
move
can you or get a different job well uh
honestly we there's people that hear
that live here that work at Chevron that
live somewhere they have apartments or
something right but with a roommate or
something like this look you actually
you know when when guys are in the
military here
especially their young guys in the
military they're they're if they got a
family they're either having to live on
house basing or maybe they go out in
town uh and a lot of them are on on
Wick and snap roll and stuff so you have
so when we were raising our kids
um and and this is a it's a choice that
you can make so Sarah was an RN she was
an ICU nurse and I was a E4 I guess
and we had our second child and I think
I made E5 by then
and we just looked at it and said hey
look
her economic earning potential was three
times what mine was but we said we have
these kids
and we chose to invest in the children
you know what I mean so Sarah stayed
home since we had our second child and
we supported ourselves
um off a single enlisted person's salary
and we had um what's that it's the um
Wick women infant and children you know
like coupons to get milk and all that
stuff I mean we're poor
but relatively speaking you know if you
you you projected across the globe we're
still incredibly wealthy if you look at
that in perspective and I think when the
department of the army just came on and
said hey instead of paying a list of
people more put them on food stamps
that's an issue yeah well that's a way
for them to save money in the long run
right but you're not giving up you're
not raising their base pay which means
you don't have to pay their retirement
as much but Echo what was your what was
your point in saying that like it's
making the comparison but you make a
good point too because
and this is actually kind of
maybe a few years after that I remember
I had a roommate too though but my
portion of the rent was like
450 bucks or something and I was making
like 300 bucks every two weeks so I was
making like 600 bucks
were you moving moving company no no no
moving over my first summer job
I was a part-time bouncer at that time
bro you ain't gonna make a bunch of
money for being a part-time bouncer no
no no no I'm just making the comparison
with like how much you can make versus
what you can kind of live off of and
have your own apartment and whatever and
you know what I'm biased that's why
because I'm like I look at like the
apartment rent right now and it's like
three thousand thirty five hundred four
thousand forty three hundred is what I
mean you're saying yeah exactly right
San Diego in UTC yeah okay there's
places in even in even in San Diego
which is super expensive there's places
that are way deeper than that in fact I
would actually even say that most places
are going to be way cheaper than that
than all of probably California really
when you think about I mean there's
certain designated cities that's like
okay it's crazy but everywhere else is
probably a lot cheaper but you make a
good point where it's like yeah I worked
at Chevron but then even you saying like
oh yeah you're starving it's kind of
like okay there that's kind of the deal
no one's really starving now you know
everyone's got to check things and they
got there this I'm thankful that people
are not hungry yeah yeah actually but
that's a whole different thing though
right then as far as like what I was
kind of trying to compare yeah but I
don't think we're way off I think I
think it's kind of similar now I think
just now we're just distracted by way
more things you know but you also got to
look at what you're gonna
except
and what you're going to do about it
because there's I was I was in Iraq we
hit this target building and we roll in
there and there's a family whatever
living there and there's a bad guy and
we got the bad guy and we're now we're
like looking at this place where it
lives and uh in the it was basically one
big room and then like two smaller
sleeping rooms but in the one big room
there was the kitchen where they made
the food and then there was like a or
there was like a sink
to make to do dishes it was the kitchen
then there was a small bench or table to
prep the food and then right next to
that was the [__] it was like well it
wasn't it wasn't a toilet it was a
trough that had a little hole but you
would [__] right there right and these
things were separated by no more than
five feet yeah
if I moved in there within 30 seconds
I'd be assessing how we're going to do
this different what changes we're going
to make we're gonna make this thing
better we're not gonna We're Not Gonna
[__] where we eat that's just the
general rule we're gonna we're gonna
make change now this family had been
living there for a long time right and I
noticed that wherever we would go
there would be some guys in the platoon
that'd be like oh we're moving into this
building now cool here's what I'm gonna
do they start fixing stuff they start
making stuff they start building stuff
they get everything set up they'd they'd
get a fan from somewhere they'd rig that
they'd make it work guys guys would just
take take action to improve their
situation that they're in and some
people aren't so if you're in an
apartment and you're working at Chevron
and you're starving you go hey you know
what this sucks I think this sucks I'm
gonna go and see what the US military if
there's an opportunity for me there
that's Derek you know I'm working at
Wendy's guess what working at Wendy's
sucks it sucks working at Wendy's they
have these fantastic uh potato wedges oh
believe me I'm not I'm not knocking I
can't say I did it really dig Wendy's
right but I'm I'm looking at it going
hey you know what this sucks I don't
want to do this
I don't want to do this for a long time
I I want to find something else okay
what options do they have in the US
military for me
you and I both kind of look towards the
military but no matter where you're at
you look around and go hey you know what
where I'm at right now kind of sucks
and if you're thinking that right now
then you say okay why does it suck what
do I need to do to improve it how can I
start building in the right direction
when we looked at when we looked at uh
how things were being manufactured
the only way to manufacture something is
do it overseen so that sucks right and
my my business partner Pete said that
sucks I want to make stuff in America
had to go and find a freaking Loom and
pull it out of an abandoned Factory and
get that thing working again and find
people who knew how to work it why
because it sucked and we're going to do
something about it it sucks that we
couldn't get boots that we wanted that
were made in America cool that sucks
what are we gonna do about it so if
you're in a situation that sucks
don't just sit there and grovel in it
figure out what you can do to make some
adjustments and listen there are there
hard times that hit people yeah you know
that's a classic extreme ownership
question that I'll get hey
I've been hit with this disease been hit
with cancer I mean I I remember
distinctly I got to ask this question uh
uh at a live event
a woman said you know my my my child was
a daughter daughter has cancer how can I
take ownership of that what am I
supposed to do how am I supposed to take
ownership how is that my fault and I
said no it's not your fault obviously
that your child got cancer
what you take ownership of is how you
respond to it right so so
I see what you're saying
so here is the
the the Nexus of personal responsibility
and governmental control
so the government's job is to make sure
that the playing field is level
and also we've gotten to the point where
we seem to have demonized
labor
so we have to not take away the Dignity
of Labor you know what I mean like I
have a picture on my phone I'm handing a
young guy named Joey his first paycheck
could ever in his life
you know what I mean that he'll remember
that 250 bucks the rest of his life
Raleigh Bevins handed me my first check
at a movie theater I remember that I
remember the guy's name that was 50
years ago or whatever you know no 50 I'm
53 so 35 years 40 or whatever it is I
don't know right so I remember Raleigh
bevin's doing that
so what is taking place in the United
States of America is that for some
reason we've allowed these folks to
convince people that if you work with
your hands you're lower
and you're lesser so even for some
people
they're okay with their circumstances by
working at Wendy's and we have to
understand that it's okay if that's what
you're going to do but then again if you
want something more you that's the part
part where you got to look inside I
think that's what you're articulating if
you're not happy with your circumstance
and the level or the playing field is
level because the government has set
conditions for everybody level
and you're living in a place where you
don't want to be it's up to you to
facilitate that change yeah well of
course there's people here there's
another leadership question I could ask
you know I got Fred and Fred he comes to
work from nine to five but he's he's not
motivated to do anything else he's
perfectly fine just just work it and I
say oh you've got a great person then
that's satisfied with where they're at
they're doing their job every day
they're working hard it doesn't mean
turn their turn their back on them and
think well I'm never going to pay
attention to Fred again no it means
every six months you check in with Fred
and you say hey Fred I know you're
waiting for your kids to you know get
through middle school or you're going to
a lot of their games
now that your kid left middle school do
you are you thinking about maybe moving
into a leadership position nope I want
to wait till they're done with high
school hey cool no problem I appreciate
the work you're doing are you familiar
with the concept of the regimental
corporal
speak to me on the regimental Corporal
all right so in the British army they
have something it's called the
regimental Corporal like in the American
Military you have to promote promote oh
yeah yeah okay so they have people that
are corporals yeah for life right
because for their career they are the
best weapons technician in the world and
they really want to do that you know
what I mean yeah and that's it's not the
English dream clearly but that's where
that guy wants to be so it the the
beauty of the United States of America
we got to get back this because we're
getting away from it is when you work
yourself into a place where you're
content it's okay to be content I mean
it's nice to be content not complacent
there's a difference so when you're
content with your family situation in
your school and your job and all that
stuff that's awesome that's your
American dream man you don't you don't
have to have a mansion in Beverly Hills
we've been just fooled I have guys that
tag me in uh social media yeah of like
Plumbing installs that are super
freaking dialed all right they're
putting an electrical sub panel and
everything is squared away
hell yeah absolutely 100 that's a trade
that's a skill and that's awesome and
I'm super stoked when I see that stuff
and that's again one thing I'm very
lucky is that you know I work with my
consulting company National front we
work with companies all over the country
and all over the world and so I get to
travel into wherever North Dakota and go
out and check out the oil rigs that are
being the the drills the guys working
what they're doing those freaking guys
are awesome the linemen up in Michigan
you know hanging wires going through
Wisconsin yeah in Wisconsin all over
right and and these people are skilled
they've got a badass job
they know that their job is completely
me they've literally Supply
power to the country it's freaking
outstanding so lineman right yeah I'm
going around right off the Great River
Road Highway 35 goes along in
Mississippi I'll have the largest
contiguous section of the Mississippi
River of any congressional district in
the country boom
it's beautiful see this great house on a
corner
big garage it's like a three-story Place
truck in the driveway this new pontoon
boat with like a 250 horsepower motor or
something up or you know cost more than
my truck
and so I whip in there because I want to
put a yard sign in this guys I go hey
man do you mind me asking what you do
for a living
lineman
it's like to trade school for two years
and he had two kids and I can't remember
his wife's name
six she was a radiology technician not a
radiologist but she okay she went to
trade school
so you got these two people who went to
trade school graduated from high school
and they're bawling dude I mean they're
living their American Dream they've got
their kids in school and I'm like
why is that wrong and you
you can't fix a toilet with a degree in
13th century French poetry and
you just can't
so why have we demonized the things that
built this nation you know what I mean
you can't you can't pump the air
conditioning in this room if you have a
degree in Communications you got to be a
metal worker
you know what I mean you have to be a
sheet metal worker to make ducting so
one of the things that I'm I'm doing
Jocko is
I consider myself and I think that the
federal government needs to do more
cheerleading like we have to cheerlead
we I did a I got endorsed by 16 and the
19 sheriffs in my district
you know what I mean because they know I
have their back 100 I I've lived in
ungoverned space I'm unwilling to do
that in the United States how do you
prevent that you support the police
officers that's what you do right so I'm
all in with these guys uh all the time
and I'm also all in with people that are
going to trade school so we have to have
people in positions of power go it is so
awesome that you are protecting me when
I say I tell Miss okay dude so I'm a
Christian
I was never afraid of being injured or
killed it was not part of my calculation
you know what I mean I for me I've read
the end of the book I've seen the end of
the movie I know what happens even be I
used to joke
um you know with my wife about this and
it was just kind of sounds like she's a
friend real funny no she's a frog man's
wife you know what I mean so
um
I was never worried about that what I
was worried about was my family
you know what I mean I was worried about
my family
and the most precious gift you can have
from my personal experience in a combat
environment is like a two-hour nap
right it's nice you get two hours of
sleep when things are squirrely why can
you get that to our nap
because your brothers have guns and
they're looking out and they're
protecting you in your sleep
that's something I cherished and I still
do who does that for my family police
officers
that's a gift
and when when people are demonizing them
they just don't understand that these
people are literally watching your
children as they sleep to make sure
they're not harmed what is more
honorable than that and Noble I don't
know yeah yeah same thing with the guys
and gals that are building our country
yep on that electrical switch honorable
and it's Noble
and things don't work without that
so the federal government needs to
cheerlead we need to tell people you're
not you're only here because these
people are working so hard
that's why you could drive your car to
work that's why you're eating
and that's why you have clothes these
are things that don't take these you
know Fancy Pants degrees and I don't
have an issue I mean I went to law
school you know what I mean I get it
higher education is very important
graduate degrees are important by the
way I finished my first year of law
school and did full-time Congress so I'm
technically on a sabbatical which
I I may or may not get back to well I'm
gonna have a greater positive effect
writing laws than I will
interpreting them yeah and again you
know I got into that I went to that for
intellectual curiosity not to you know
be Perry Mason or something like that
but anyway so that's the next thing I'm
doing cheerleading check that's the only
questions
[Music]
you got to test him a little bit you
know he's gonna be up against the big
dog the big uh tough questions that's it
for right now okay right on Derek any
closing thoughts man
um
I uh
I again I want people to be encouraged
and you know how are you encouraged is
you you sit down and you you practice
actively practice gratitude
for what you got
and you understand that you are
empowered
to change your circumstances and I know
that because I was raised dirt poor
in a single home
High School Dropout the whole works and
jerks and I'm going to Congress next
year so if I can do this
you can do it it's it's the same reason
I told you man I knew I could graduate
from buds because there is a seal with a
trident on in front of me
right you know means it's possible
so act
right it is possible so act uh awesome
boards to close on thanks for joining us
brother
um thanks for your service well thank
you for yours that goes really nice to
meet you man like Quest I'll give you my
phone or we can call me anything right
on sounds good I think you already got
it well God bless you guys and your your
listeners and
um I just wish you the best Oh Hey
where's that thing oh we got a baseball
bat check this out so this
this was made by
The Three Brothers back company
it's in Wisconsin
got a hold of these guys a couple played
college balls it's actually um four
brothers and a sister
but um they decided to start making
um baseball bats So This Bat is it meets
all the standards to be used in the
Major League Baseball and these dudes
that spot this old building started
making these things yeah so what
happened with bats is I did like a okay
long story on the bats here's the long
story on the bats
when I went to Iraq platoon Commander
2003 yeah
when did you go there for the first time
2004 I was in Afghanistan in 2000 okay I
was in Iraq in 2000 when you were
Afghanistan in 2003 was America sending
a bunch of stuff over there just like
care packages and like sunscreens still
are okay so that was going on and for
whatever reason you're descended
sunscreen and like Eminem just all the
stuff and they would send
baseball gloves and baseballs and
baseball bats so for whatever reason we
had a bunch of baseball bats so we're
living in a you know this was 2003 the
war had kind of
well this is this fall of 2004 2003 so
the war wasn't very deep there wasn't
all this infrastructure there wasn't
like a Wendy's on the base and
everything like this yet and so we were
briefing in this crappy room with uh you
know like a sheet hung up on the wall
and I would brief I would go and get one
of the bats from this MWR the morale
welfare record well from Recreation
bucket which had three baseball bats in
it that somebody some cool person from
America threw him into a package and
sent him to support the troops yeah
which is beautiful and so I would walk
over there grab a bat that's how I brief
and one of my friends has a that has a
video of me briefing with the bat
and you know that's just like how I
would point to like Hey we're gonna go
here we're gonna move over there
and so then when I was a task unit
Commander it kind of continued on that
we had like a briefing bat
and then we did a video the other day
and I was just like talking about
leadership or something I was holding a
bat and I forget what bat it was it'll
be that one in the future in the future
will be this one but then now a bunch of
people now I have I think I think I've
received five baseball bats from various
people custom baseball bats I mean
there's you can see there's another one
right over there I got a few of them at
home but uh yeah this one is this one's
awesome made in America it says def core
pro model deaf 434 Three Brothers back
company dude that is in my district and
that is another example of people saying
I have got a good idea there's I'll tell
you one I got to get out of here
um there's we sir concrete concrete
company
Joe just died um gosh it must have been
six seven months ago
Joe had like six kids and they had a
house and marries his wife
um and he's like I got an idea I got an
idea
how to make concrete this certain way to
make this stuff and it's gonna work
mortgages his house again
so you want to talk about risk homeless
Wisconsin six kids
that would happen if you failed but he's
like I have an idea he died a
billionaire
Jack because he was like check on the
billionaire part not so much to check on
the diet part but I mean if you're gonna
die you might as well do it in a million
billionaire yeah right so
that's one of the things that people
demonize business people I'm like the
hardest
that I would say the wealthiest people I
know are some of the hardest working
people I know and you know that's their
thing that's their metric as I started
off you know I still do this
um I collect relationships with people
to me that is my metric of success how
many people do I know at what level do I
know them how can I help them will they
reach out to me if they need something
and can I facilitate that need that's my
metric of success it always has been
Sarah Jane and I live on my enlisted
retirement you know what I mean because
we don't chase nickels I just it's not
my thing
but if if that if you're a businessman
you're a metric or woman your metric of
success more likely than not is
financial so therefore if you're doing
this and that's the metric of success
you should be wealthy as a business
person if you're a doctor you should be
caring people
um so
I love that about this job because I get
to meet the Most Fascinating People like
those dudes that make that bat for you
and it was an offhand comment wait you
know this Jocko guy when did you meet
him and when did they get the bat to you
to bring it hand carry it to me that got
shipped overnight to my mother-in-law's
house it would was delivered yesterday
so I talked to the cats and they're like
oh you know this charcoal willink guy
I'm like you know and they said it like
you know because apparently it's a big
deal I mean I don't know this stuff dude
like I didn't know you had this it was
like you don't know he has all this
stuff because I started looking into it
and he wrote all these books and
everything and I go like if you're an
accountant
you know would you like go watch a movie
about tax season or you know you
wouldn't like so why would I be looking
into Jocko I know the dude he's an
awesome cat you know why would I be
following him around so um I didn't but
they're like that offhand comment I go
yeah man I've known it for like 30 years
I guess now from team one right and
they're like you are kidding me and like
no so they follow your podcast they
watch it I think that they've taken a
lot of your lessons because they're
incredibly squared away dudes sure and
Family's awesome and just their name
they have you know too many siblings to
put it on a bat that's why it's three
brothers Bat Company but yeah yeah so
that was made for you and I have one
um it's in my office which uh I think
again cheerleading for people is what
that should be a primary function of
politics I mean clearly you must write
um functional policy and translate ideas
into action and you do that through the
written word Vice a gun like we used to
do but the rest is just telling telling
people about other people
you know what I mean like if if if if I
could
if I could tell you about all the people
that I know
and what they've done
it would just be an endless conversation
and to me that means I am the most
successful person in the world because
that's my metric of success
awesome man well uh like I said thanks
for coming down yeah appreciate it
thanks for thanks for the service of
your family by the way uh what the what
the military wives and spouses for the
bomb go through
um incredible the kids that grow up
you know without dads around without
moms around
um really really challenging so thanks
to your family as well and uh I'll pass
it on I wish you fair win fair wins
following seas and a lot of votes there
you go get them all right bro thanks
cheers
oh one more thing I forgot van
ordenforcongress.com vanordon for
congress.com on Facebook on Twitter on
Instagram you're at Derek d e r r i c k
Van Orden o r d e n and you're up on all
those different platforms you got a
YouTube channel as well I do so we can
you can explore you got lots of 30
second Clips on there those are your
little ad spots I do those I also make
these little videos and just try to
explain where do you put your little
videos uh they go mostly on my social
media okay and then we also rip them
over to YouTube so so it's all out there
if you want to get a feel a better feel
if over three hours of conversation if
you don't think like you feel feel like
you know Derek yet you want to get to
know you might know Derek do you know
vano do you know vano do you know
dvo all right man thank you
and with that Derek Van Orden vano dvo
dvo that's what we're going with dvo dvo
has left the building uh a lot going on
in the life of dvo that's true
some pretty uh important themes
throughout
talk the discussion um
um and you know what I just realized you
know he was in that movie did you know
he was in that movie he mentioned it but
then we and I like pulled him back to
talk about something else and then he's
using the movie the movie is called Act
of Valor I did not know that yeah so he
was he played a scene in that movie he
was an interrogator and came in and he
it was pretty funny uh
just he was kind of like just him with
but being super aggressive
[Music]
uh but yeah man what a uh what a
dedication to jump back into this stuff
and get after it but um hey
with that appreciate everyone listening
appreciate the support and if you want
to support
you mentioned something real quick okay
thank you he's waiting for you to chime
in with something or you're just sitting
there looking puzzle
I was thinking about the movie actually
okay and him playing himself not much of
a stretch not no it's not a
demonstration of range yep you know
similar to you
yeah yeah they pretty much the exact
same thing but you guys did mention
something in passing seemingly
insignificant but it stuck with me
you're talking about he talked about the
the incident where he left his rifle in
the other car and you know he just has
his pistol and you said that's not gonna
cut it real quick why is that I mean I
can kind of maybe understand but
obviously I've never been in a gunfight
so what he's talking about is
the enemy puts indirect fire on you
which is mortars maybe Rockets Rockets
aren't really indirect but but they
basically are are lobbing bombs at you
the purpose of them doing that is number
one that could could be just a singular
purpose hey we're just gonna try and
randomly throw some bombs at people and
kill whoever we can random mortars maybe
we kill one or two Americans but they
could also do it so when mortars are
coming you have to get you have to take
cover
so now we get the enemy can get you to
take cover so they drop a couple mortars
while you're hiding
they commence a ground assault
either with a vehicle-borne IED that's
what they would do in ramadi was it was
it was it was very aggressive they would
they would hit you with indirect fire as
the indirect fire is hitting they start
laying down machine gun fire as the
machine gun fires coming in then comes
IEDs vehicle-borne IEDs and they overran
several
several uh friendly positions in ramadi
by doing that horrible
so
when you so he gets mortared and he had
told the guys like hey when you get
mortared give it a second
and see what's going on let it develop
and see what's developing but then as
soon as it kind of stops boom push out
perimeter so then if anybody attacks you
can fend them off
so
he's pushing out to set perimeter and
all he has is a pistol the pistol is not
a good weapon for a freaking gun fight
so and that's really the part that I was
wondering like it's I feel like I
understand it kind of but the way I've
heard you say it and my friend Jeremy he
mentioned this one time we're talking he
was like yeah a pistol is no match for a
rifle so I'm like okay see how you say
it's not even close like why is that
because they're a rifle you can just aim
it better more range the range is 10
times as much 10 times yeah like like
sure you can shoot someone in kind of at
50 yards with uh with a pistol if you're
really really good anyone just about
anyone can pick up a rifle and shoot
someone at 50 yards like almost anywhere
but you can also shoot someone at 500
yards so it may even be even more that
because because really
might be like 12 or 15 times more
accurate and ease of shooting yeah and
then the impact right you know the
impact of a rifle round is devastating
you know it can punch through body armor
certain levels of body armor it can grip
through a car you know certain parts of
a car so you're just gonna get better
penetration with a battle rifle than you
are with a pistol pistol and what's
funny is when I got to the SEAL Teams
we used to use the
the MP5 which is a nine millimeter sub
machine gun a submachine gun is
basically a machine gun that shoots
pistol rounds so they're small small
little bullets
and
luckily we went away from that because
it's cool for literal Close Quarters
combat so if you're inside of a building
then it there is some potential for it
actually I think that the that weapon
the a submachine gun like the Heckler
MP5 I think is a great weapon for like
home self-defense
because it's
not going to penetrate through a bunch
of walls it's really easy to shoot like
really easy to shoot so if someone you
know let's say you want to get your wife
oh self Home Defense weapon now look she
could also get a shotgun
you know maybe a a smaller gauge shotgun
like not a 12 gauge shotgun but like a
20 gauge shotgun pretty easy to handle
kind of a point and shoot scenario so
that would be one option but I think a
good option another good option would be
a little submachine gun that she feels
super confident shooting can we shoot
machine gun to California well this is
semi-automatic semi
I don't know what the legality is
on the MP5 well no you can't have a
fully automatic weapon in California no
I don't think so
without certain like criteria criteria
they have some the the laws the laws in
California for weapons are really kind
of ridiculous
because all they do is they create a law
and then the gun manufacturers create
things that get around the law yeah and
in it's just weird yeah
they just like this weird dance it's a
weird dance yeah instead of just being
like hey look this is what you and it
doesn't make any sense the whole I mean
look you hear this stuff all the time
about oh what is it like what's an
assault weapon yeah and while an assault
weapon is this type of thing yeah 15
assault rifle 15.
but it's because of like the shape of
the grip like a pistol grip makes it an
assault a muzzle suppressor a flash
suppressor makes it an assault weapon
according to this weird
thing so instead of having a pistol grip
they'll like put this weird shape thing
that serves the same function as a
pistol grip yeah but it's actually not a
pistol grip at all yeah but it is a
pistol grip it gives you the same
function they just do all this dumb
silly things and then and then the gun
manufacturers make something that just
overcomes that maybe it's a little bit
awkward or whatever not as cool but it's
just a silly dance it's just like you
said it's a silly dance yeah the and
when I was
browsing
um one of the guys there said something
one of the main guys there might have
been the owner he he said something
interesting where he's like yeah well
one of the main problems is the people
who make the laws and even propose the
laws they don't know anything about them
so they the it just it's the the mere
conception of the law comes out of
ignorance yeah it's just it's just dumb
yeah it's just dumb so it's uh one of
the things about California that's just
really bizarre yeah it's just bizarre
they make laws that that literally don't
make sense yeah yep when they land right
it's like wait like what's the issue
here that is solved and they're like
well this one goes well that didn't even
solve it didn't even solve it it
actually kind of made some more issues
yeah and then made a lot of people mad
who are kind of in the know meanwhile I
bike I can buy Desert Eagle 50 calibers
50 caliber round uh-huh I can shoot with
one hand if I want to that seems kind of
dangerous
could be I mean depending on what kind
of
thing you're shooting at you know how
dumb you are I'm pretty dumb yeah let's
face it but yeah yeah that is uh that's
interesting though that's good
interesting to know about the pistol
versus rifle yeah yeah I didn't realize
it was that much of a difference huge
difference it's it's almost incomparable
probably because I'm thinking of movies
you know how like in you know Lethal
Weapon remember yeah but what part I
don't know he was just really good at
aiming so he would be like at one
distance I don't know oh yeah he shoots
the smiley face into the target yes yes
yes yes that was one of the parts for
sure yeah that's really depending on
what range that would be difficult to do
I think in the movie it was far away
like pretty far shocked yeah he pushed
it pretty all the way back that was kind
of the thing
yeah
very interesting there you go he said a
lot of cool stuff though and you know
they like I like hearing cool stuff like
presented a certain way
um but at the same time I do like kind
of like what it says and when you think
about it you'll be like oh yeah man you
know it only kind of Dawns on you like
certain things he said if you keep your
head down you won't see the world around
you that's a really good point and even
metaphorically you know how like if you
stay in the house all the time or if you
don't you know like they say work life
balance I get that that that's a thing
or whatever but let's say you don't see
your friends so you don't you don't
socialize or or you don't talk to a
bunch of people as much because you're
focused on this or that or whatever you
you'll miss out a lot of battle fish
like beneficial stuff for you and your
your whole goals right you can miss out
on key elements of those goals if you
keep your head down in in all these when
I was in my first seal platoon
we my my leading petty officer he he had
this thing like he would want to go out
party right oh yeah and he would say
always go out
yeah like oh you know we're gonna always
go out and I took that because I was
like hardcore right and we always go out
like always go out surfing go out
like there's a training Mission always
go out oh always go out so yeah I always
go out party cool get it I'm I approve
of that when I was younger you know
now I'm older I'm not so much supported
that you know what I mean but always go
out always go on the mission always Step
Up always volunteer always go out always
the waves always go out you know snow
always go out yeah always go out so I I
kind of adopted that attitude a little
bit not only strictly with
this guy one time he was super drunk and
he's I think he had to go to the
bathroom and we pulled back into the
barracks in Guam
and he like gets out of the car and it's
dark and he goes running
across the from the parking lot to the
barracks there was you know maybe a
hundred yards of grass and he goes
running and I'm just kind of walking
because I'm not in a rush and I think he
had to go to the bathroom
and all of a sudden he just like
disappears Falls
and then I just hear this ow
yeah you fell in a hole or something
he's just like wow
yeah so there you go
with that um we talked about some of the
stuff today hey jockle fuel get yourself
some of these goat new improved flavors
do I I am apologizing for the previous
flavors comparatively comparatively
speaking the new flavors are just
amazing and look with the old flavors it
was like oh you know I got my favorite
flavor don't really like that one this
one's okay yeah you actually don't want
to drink this one over here you know
it's kind of that thing yeah now no
matter what you can go party mix yeah
and you're gonna like them all right you
can grab one grab the other they all
they're all freaking tasty so if you if
you were uh a little bit maybe cautious
or concerned before you tried me like uh
now you can just get right in there just
get right in there and get yourself some
some go so fully good for you by the way
which is a totally different thing I was
watching the show Netflix show I don't
know it wasn't my show my wife was
watching it my wife's watching
from the vicinity of my eyes I saw and
they're they're making this um this
scene of this girl she was trying to
travel she was running away from some
Killers I don't know something so she
was driving up to Maine by the way and
she stops at this convenience she's all
disheveled shops at this and she's a
disheveled character just to begin with
you know like does it doesn't have her
[__] together kind of thing she stuff to
this convenience store and just gets
like in the scene I see what they're
trying to portray there that she's just
like doesn't make the greatest of
decisions in general so like what does
she get like chips yeah and like you
know not a good not a sandwich or not a
you know she's getting chips and then
she gets an energy drink
and it was like a recognizable brand oh
and I was like interesting how they
chose that brand for to
convey this message about this character
and this point of the story interesting
and I was thinking oh because you know
it's a brand you recognize you're like
okay cool oh I recognized and ran on the
movie kind of a thing I was like oh
that'd be cool if there was some Jocko
go in there right it would not fit the
scene exactly right to be squared away
squared away you'd have to be legit
exactly right I thought I thought that
was kind of interesting bro without
opening up a can
80cc you and I just went to the ADCC
yeah Championship oh yeah which was
awesome we'll do some kind of a thing
about that a little debrief on that at a
future time but we had the ready to
drink Mulk there
how many of them did you have oh one
really I had like because I was there
for two how did you only have one well
because I drank one and then it was like
the next opportunity I had they were
like uh Brian was like because he
couldn't give him what
or something like that something
happened where they couldn't get away
you got scammed yeah when they were like
oh here they had like five a day yeah I
was there for two days yeah they're
freaking so tasty and so good for you
hey and this is cool good news
we have been having a hard time finding
the manufacturer for it
we just got cleared out we just
built that relationship with this
manufacturer we got millions of ready to
drink milk coming it's delicious way
better than other brands you and I just
had a little taste test comparison and
it's not even close it's not even close
and this is a big brand we tried as a
matter of fact my daughter Rana did a
taste test while we were at Camp
chocolate milk legit chocolate milk yeah
from a milk carton like like ready-made
chocolate milk but not any kind of just
chocolate milk that's just made to taste
good versus Mulk
chocolate milk
she picked up my my daughter Randall
does not play around like if she's gonna
tell you what's up she's looking she's
schooling yeah she's kind of like
offensive right she's kind of like gonna
bring it
she kind of raised her eyebrows she's
like oh damn yeah yeah the milk so we
got ready to drink milk coming worldwide
um well not worldwide really Nationwide
you're gonna be able to order it uh so
check that out jockoffuel.com go to Wawa
go to Wawa and just clean the shelves in
there let them know what's up
the the more you buy from Wawa the more
flavors they're gonna bring in the more
will open up that supply chain so going
to Wawa clear shelves
vitamin shop
we got pink Mist at vitamin shop right
now it's the only place I think you can
get it we had to run that first run of
them vitamin shoppe's been awesome they
got everything in there so go in there
and just get some get some pink Mist
it's tasty so we're at 80cc as you
mentioned and
I'm not gonna say who actually I'm gonna
say who's my wife she was like Hey this
pink one is good this would be perfect
with vodka in it
[Music]
she said it and I was like you know what
you're kind of right because remember
back in the day Red Bull vodka or
whatever right like that was like kind
of that was kind of like a death trap
kind of thing like you're you're not
doing the right thing with a red bull
and a vodka and then drinking them all
all night that's bad
but think about it the pink Mist might
balance out some of the repercussions
look it's not the right thing but it's
not it's less it's less wrong than going
with Red Bull and vodka yeah it's
definitely less wrong than that kind of
balances itself out a little bit it's
not balanced it feels it feels like a
balance but it's a move in the right
direction let's face it we're not going
out and drinking vodka and thinking that
there's that this is gonna make it okay
yeah yeah but it felt like a violation
if vodka is kind of on the schedule yeah
which I don't recommend right it's not
on my schedule at all zero percent okay
but if it's on your schedule yeah and
you want to mitigate the issues that
you're going to have then it's not going
to mitigate you going to jail it's not
going to mitigate a DUI it's not going
to mitigate you getting arrested it's
not going to mitigate you spending all
your money on stupid [__] it's not going
to mitigate any of that no apparently it
may give you a little bit of a less
hangover in the morning we'll go with
that
uh so there you go jogofuel.com get some
of that originusa.com just got back from
my hunt it's another one we should just
do a podcast about the hunt the lessons
just but hey we made Hunt gear remember
I had said if if the hunt gear wasn't
ready I was hunting in a loincloth that
was my plan
luckily it didn't have to break it into
the loincloth scenario everything is
freaking legit man it's just so so good
to go
um super stoked the team from origin the
team in North Carolina the team in Maine
everyone putting that stuff together is
just turned out
freaking legit so stoked and everyone's
kind of stoked man everybody that I saw
that hunted
was like hell yeah hell yeah
thank you for making this in the United
States of America yeah that's legit so
did you see anything yes I shot an elk
hell yeah
bro there's a lot and there's a lot of
people
this is a very tough year for hunting uh
there's been a lot of rain out west so
there's been a lot of grass a lot of
grass means there's a lot of eating that
means the elk are fat
which means apparently
and talking to Hunters they're like well
all that fat on the elk means it's
harder to kill them oh for real because
they bleed less the blood doesn't flow
as easily
so it's been a really challenging year
there's a lot of people that that didn't
get elk and uh it's been a tough year I
was very lucky very fortunate
to get one yeah and I'm at a point now I
got four elk with four arrows which is
kind of I told that to lay from life
like dude you are you freaking lucky
bastard I'm like I'll take it man 100
yeah um so what do you what did you do
with the elk
what do you mean what did you do with
the elk they're eating it yeah oh so you
bring it back yeah yeah of course oh
yeah you drove huh yeah yeah yeah okay
okay yeah I understand Elks for dinner
bro yeah I understand but it's happening
you know I'm just saying does everyone
like if you shoot it is that the common
thing of course I mean it's it's you
know it's a few hundred pounds worth of
meat yeah but I've heard of like oh
they'll give it to the who you know what
I'm thinking of this one actually a few
stories I heard in like it was in a
different country oh okay and then they
gave it to like the village or something
like that yeah if there's villagers that
were like starving maybe Utah
there's no villager Starving in Utah
yeah yeah I didn't think so uh but so we
got the stuff made in America
originusa.com if you want to support
American company that's bringing like I
told Derek is there anything cooler than
BR than buying machines in another
country and that were sold to that
country and bringing them back to
America yeah the conceptually cool to
beat that one one time okay remember
back in the day the little it's this
little where it went back okay uh it's
called roller racer do you remember that
thing what is it it was like okay so
think of a skateboard okay think of a
hard bicycle seat okay but a little bit
bigger okay
bicycle handlebars on a half of a super
skinny skateboard with a pivot and then
the front of the skateboard okay so you
sat on it with handlebars down like this
and you wiggle it back and forth and it
would go all right it was called roller
racing people on that thing yeah yeah it
was like a little yeah I didn't have one
as seen on TV scenario this is back in
maybe 90 maybe probably before that 80s
80s anyway
so one of our friends neighbors had that
and they left it out on the road they
lived right up the road so technically I
didn't steal it but I just wanted to use
it so I grabbed it and I used it for a
few days I was gonna bring it back for
real I for real I know likely story this
is not sounding good I didn't bring it
back but I the plan was to bring it back
at some point right so I was using it
and then I just left it out in my yard
that's how right I live on koi
a few days later it was gone and then we
passed by that house every day and I saw
it back at their house
I was like oh they came in kind of
took it back or whatever then the guy in
a good way like oh they go they grabbed
it back no big deal or kind of like it's
totally neutral in my opinion I was like
oh it's theirs you know like I wasn't
gonna return it yeah and I still want to
play with it for a little bit but hey
man it is there so whatever and then the
kid confronted me about it he's like hey
you thought you were all slick huh and I
was like what do you mean he's like yeah
cause you ripped off the roller racer
and I ripped it off back
that's what he did with the Looms that's
what you guys do same exact thing man I
thought it was cool
how your brain works for the first time
I've kind of started a Ponder bro like
how you got to that story from what I
just said and try to connect them it's
the exact same thing that's what I'm
saying
originusa.com get American-made stuff
we'll leave it at that we won't we'll
try not to lure out any stories of
Madness
from uh from you also speaking of
Madness Jocko store chocolate store is
called Jocko store so you go to
jocklestore.com it's where you can get
your discipline equals Freedom shirts we
got a new one out standard issue
there's nothing standard about it it's
freaking awesome that's this is the
feedback I'm getting from the field but
yeah it's a good one also we have the
Sherlock which is the subscription
service it seems like you've been
getting a little wild on the shirt
Locker design yes and we're going harder
even
in the next few let's say the next three
months are gonna be kind of like oh can
I see I see what you did there we're
very excited about the new design
Jack right on that's uh Jocko store.com
subscribe to the podcast
don't forget about um
the Jocko underground right Taco
underground.com we don't know what's
going to happen with this platform did
Derek say anything today that could get
us banned
maybe you mentioned Donald Trump oh yeah
there you go that can be a flag I said
the word Trump so yeah that could be so
in the event that we get banned because
we don't control the platform that
you're currently listening on unless
you're on Draco underground if you're on
Draco underground we're good we're still
here we're talking to you but if you're
not you're like wait what happened what
Jocko and Echo just got lazy they
stopped making podcasts
hopefully that doesn't happen but if it
does we'll be ready Jocko
underground.com eight dollars and 18
cents a month
to support that and if you we make a
little extra podcast for that we answer
your questions if you want to get
involved in that if you can't afford it
we still want you in the game email
assistance.com underground.com we got a
YouTube channel we got psychological
warfare we got Dakota Meyers got
flipsidecanvas.com
I've written a bunch of books
publishing books publish a book by Holly
McKay check that one out
and then but you you know the books that
I've written if you don't go to Amazon
and
put in Jocko willink and then you'll see
books that I've written and you can
order some of them you can order kids
books get the before you even you know
you know you got to get the uh
oxygen mask on yourself first yes I do
if you go to Amazon right now to go you
know what chocolate sounds like he knows
what he's talking about here
don't order the adult book get your kids
the warrior kid books first get the
oxygen mask on them then save yourself
so the opposite of the airplane no it's
the same in the airplane no you don't
put it on yourself first right yes okay
opposite of the opposite of the up
you're right so I could see how you can
get confused yeah I'm saying because it
seems like hey save the women and
children first kind of a scenario but
hey you can't say nobody if you're
suffocating that's what I'm saying but
we're if you're cognizant enough to
order something from Amazon order the
kids books first because you look your
life is half over at this point you know
you got kids you you've kind of already
blown it yeah
you're one foot in the grave but your
kids they got their whole life ahead
might as well get them on the paths too
it's true let them rise up the my
daughter was she she learned her
timetables last year and then this year
she's in literally the the where where
the work in one Mark yeah same exact
scenario so but she learned her time
still but she forgot all of a lot of
them so she's doing this other stuff you
know you know how you kind of need to
know the time
same exact deal she starts crying and
all this stuff she doesn't know her time
Stables she's nine years old she's all
this stuff I was like we've read that
flash cards made him boom right on the
spot man on the spot I said you read
this whole book twice by the way and
you're still crying about this right now
so you mean these flashcards on the spot
we do we went slows a lot of it was
review she already knew it but so when
we ironed out the wrinkles easy money
back in the game back in the game back
in the manual yep
Warrior kid get your kids on the path uh
excellent front have a leadership
consultancy we solve problems with
leadership ah you heard me talk about a
little bit today when you got problems
in a company in an organization the
problems are leadership problems you
want us to help you solve those problems
with these principles called
echelonfront.com
we have some Live Events you can come to
they get sold out where next one we're
doing is in Atlanta it's sold out sorry
but if you want to go go to there check
out events come to some of our Live
Events we have a online training academy
where look leadership takes practice not
once a year
not once every six months you need to
get in the gym the leadership gym
the life gym
extreme ownership.com come on there take
some courses we're on there live a bunch
you can ask me questions
go check that out
and if you want to support
service members active and retired you
want to support their families
gold star families check out Markley's
mom
she's got a charity organization
if you want to donate to that or you
want to get involved go to America's
Mighty Warriors dot org and don't forget
about Micah Fink
taken
taken vets out into the wilderness
so they can find solutions to their
problems
in the darkness they can find the light
Heroes and horses.org and once again if
you want to follow and support Derek
vano Van Orden
dvo that's what we're going with yeah
dvo
you wanna want to support him Van Orden
for congress.com
and then on Facebook on Twitter on
Instagram he's at derekvanorden
you can see the guy's got a big heart
and he's trying to help I say we go
support him and it's certainly if you're
in that District in Wisconsin he brought
me cheese bro you see the curd yeah he
brought me cheese he brought me cookies
which you ate I sampled yes
you ate the cookies because we're not
the discipline doesn't allow cookies
over on my side of the table okay a
cheese curd which I have not tried
before apparently I gotta cook it no no
no he said he said deep fryer or
something oh you can yeah yeah for sure
cheese curd is like you know what that
is technically well you know my wife is
very is from the Tillman Cheese Factory
area so we go visit that one every year
when we go when I go but it's the pre
it's like it's it's one of the final
processes before they do another one or
two processes to make actual cheese so
it's like the base does it taste good
depends how you do it that one does
because there's like garlic regular
cheese curd not really it's like I think
that stuff's getting fried in a pan
that's what I think yeah I can see that
I haven't ever had fries
it just seems I don't know too because
he brought it in like a bag
it doesn't I don't think it's supposed
to it's supposed to be refrigerator
I could see how they pulled it out of
the bottom of like a travel bag I have
dvo was not Forward Thinking on his
transport of cheese curd yeah for Jocko
I think you might be wrong
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah but
we appreciate it Derek yes we appreciate
it we will try it out we will see what's
up uh of course that's that's Derek van
Warden on all those social medias and if
you Echo and I are on there too if you
want to follow us on the Twitter on the
gram on the Facebook
I'm at Jocko willink watch out for the
algorithm because it'll kinda it'll kind
of grab you
and thanks once again to Derek for
joining us thanks for sharing some of
those Lessons Learned
well thanks for everything you have done
for America and what you are trying to
do for America right now we are here to
support and thanks to all of our
military personnel that have surfed and
are serving
nothing poor more important than what
you do to keep us free and we are
grateful for your service and thanks to
our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service all First Responders as
Derek pointed out
you're the one that protects you're the
ones that protect our kids
as they sleep at night and keep us safe
and we are grateful for your service as
well
and everyone else out there you know we
start off with some George Washington
today
close it out with a little George
Washington as well he said to be
prepared for war is one of the most
effectual means of preserving peace
and that goes for life as well and you
take a guy like Derek
up from nothing
and he's prepared for war his whole life
and I think he's going to be ready for
whatever politics can throw at him
and for the rest of us
I think we also have to prepare for war
because it's coming and look I'm not
talking about outright literal War but
in some form
in some form you will be at War for your
health for your business for your family
for your community War comes in many
forms
so be prepared for it and of course
the best way to do that
is to go out there every day
and get after it
until next time this is Echo and Jocko
out